hello everyone welcome to the March 2023
ask me anything edition of the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
it's hard to believe it's March 2023 I
know that's a Eternal kind of thing time
keeps passing
um we got our first snowfall of the Year
here in Baltimore just the other day not
much of a snowfall technically snow was
falling from the sky but it was only for
a short period of time not that much
instantly evaporated but it struck home
the fact that it was our first and it's
almost March when I'm recording this and
that's very very rare you know Baltimore
is not a frigid Northeast climate
technically south of the Mason-Dixon
Line even though just a bit but usually
uh as I know from living in Philadelphia
for a long time which is not that far
away you will get snow in the winter
sometimes quite a lot and this year and
apparently in recent years there's just
been essentially zero snow
also when I arrived here last summer
July and August were brutally hot and
quite humid at the same time now you may
have heard the world is getting warmer
the climate is heating up the fact that
we've had a very warm winter and very
hot summer doesn't by itself imply that
climate change is happening but it's
compatible with that and the reason why
I'm mentioning it is not because I
advocate people thinking about the
reality of climate change based on their
local weather conditions but because it
does drive home how that visceral impact
really does matter you know we're moving
in to the phase of global climate change
where people are going to start to
notice it's going to be harder and
harder for people to stick their heads
in the sand and pretend that nothing is
happening in in some sense if we
completely stabilize the climate
immediately right now at the present
value value of all the different
parameters we'd be fine it wouldn't be a
huge difference from what things had
before the real problem is that it's
going to continue to deviate from what
it usually had been so it's important
that people catch on that this is a real
thing and uh I don't like the fact that
the summers are really going to be very
warm around here on average some of them
might not be right there are
fluctuations around whatever mean is
happening uh the winter being warm is is
kind of nice although it would be nice
to see snow sometimes anyway it all just
feeds into this question of What kinds
of things make people
change their minds update their
credences on various things of course
people have been following science and
don't have some hidden political agenda
or explicit political agenda already
know the climate change is happening but
to feel it in your bones uh can be
effective be powerful for people who are
not already there so I'm interested to
see what will happen going forward as
people notice that things are not like
they used to be anyway that's not very
profound thought but it's all I have to
begin I want to get right into the AMA
it's a long one as usual I feel bad that
I had to not answer a lot of good
questions
um
reminder that these questions are asked
by people who support mindscape on
patreon uh you can be one of those
people wouldn't that be awesome go to
patreon.com Sean M Carroll sign up for a
dollar per episode or however much you
want to pay and you get to ask these
questions as well as getting access to
ad-free versions of the mindscape
podcast there's also a podcast webpage
if you want transcripts we have
transcripts of every episode you can
search the transcripts if you like oh
and here is something very fun
um in the AMA today someone pointed out
that they would like a an index of all
the questions that have been asked
because I mentioned that sometimes the
reason why I will not answer a certain
question is not because it's a good
question uh but because I feel like I've
already answered it several times so
Siddhartha has gone in and made a
question and answer
record of all AMA questions into a table
format that's available on Google Docs I
will put a link to that in these show
notes because I was mentioning that we
have show notes transcripts Etc that's
on the podcast home page
preposterousuniverse.com podcast
available to everyone not just to
patreon supporters so you can find all
that and soon you'll be able to search
the amas uh of course you can only
search the exact words it's not a super
smart algorithm or anything like that
but yeah maybe that will help people
find out whether or not their question
had been asked so with that let's go
foreign
[Music]
the first question this month is from
Scott who says do you have any comments
on the recent astrophysics news that
supermassive black holes might be the
source of and coupled to accelerating
cosmological expansion and what does it
even mean to say these supermassive
black holes have dark energy inside
their event Horizons this actually it
was not just Scott who asked this
question several people asked this
question sorry other people for not
mentioning your names but I thought I
could just condense it into this one
thing I don't have anything especially
brilliant to say about this but I wanted
to explain why I don't have anything
especially brilliant to say about this
so what Scott is referring to is there
was a paper that just came out by Duncan
Farah and collaborators and I think
there were two papers and these are you
know respectable people these are not
crazies off the street and it got a lot
of attention in the media and elsewhere
and the claim is that black holes can
grow faster than you think you know we
know that there are black holes out
there in the universe we know that
galaxies tend to have supermassive black
holes at the center of them
we think
by the measurements of the actual black
holes that even though they're
supermassive millions or billions times
the mass of the Sun they're still very
very subdominant compared to the amount
of matter and energy in stars and gas
and dust not to mention dark matter and
dark energy you know the usual standard
picture is five percent of the universe
is by mass or by energy I should say is
ordinary matter the particles and atoms
and things like that that we've already
know their types because we discovered
them here in the laboratory about 25
percent is dark matter which is some
other kind of matter some kind of
particle or something like that that has
not yet been discovered in the
laboratory and doesn't interact
noticeably with light therefore it is
dark matter and 70 is dark energy which
doesn't matter at all it's something
that has a more or less constant energy
density even as the universe expands the
amount of dark energy per cubic
centimeter remains approximately
constant and that's really the trick
that is what it means to be dark energy
because the important thing that the
dark energy does is that it makes the
universe accelerate it changes the way
that the expansion rate of the universe
evolves with time so that it seems that
the universe is going through an
accelerated rate of expansion this uh
was discovered back in 1998 among other
people by my current colleague at Johns
Hopkins and former mindscape guest Adam
Reese and this is the most uh important
thing in the universe as it were for
cosmologists these days we don't
understand exactly why the dark energy
has the magnitude it does etc so it's a
very respectable thing to try to
understand Dark Energy better and the
claim is that black holes are the dark
energy effectively that black holes grow
right they Creed they were not billion
solar mass black holes at the birth of
the universe they came into existence
and are growing and the claim is that
they grow so fast
that even though the number of black
holes in a region of space stays let's
imagine that it stays roughly constant
so you would think that as the volume
goes up the density of energy in the
black holes goes down but these fields
are saying no no the black holes
individually grow so fast that the total
amount of energy density in black holes
remains approximately constant as the
universe expands and therefore the black
holes are kind of like dark energy and
maybe they are the dark energy that is
making the universe accelerate
and so the question is do I have any
comments on this so my comments are I
haven't really read the papers very
carefully and the reason why is because
they seem very unlikely to be on the
right track to me and I have to try to
be super duper fair about this because I
haven't read the papers so how can I say
that they're probably not on the right
track first and foremost I could be
wrong about this right because I haven't
read the papers I haven't checked the
calculations or anything like that so
I'm going on various feelings and priors
that I have and it's a completely fair
question to ask given how important it
would be if this result were on the
right track why doesn't someone who
cares about cosmology and is a
professional scientist spend the time to
read the papers and check them
and that's the interesting question to
talk about and the answer is that you
know to me from my perspective when I
read these papers as someone who's done
a lot of work on dark energy and general
relativity I wrote a textbook on general
relativity it seems completely at odds
with all of my expectations and
intuitions about how cosmology Works
about how black holes work about how we
inventory what is in the universe that's
not to say that it's not right I mean
maybe after all my expectations are
somehow wrong but when I see a paper
even a published paper by you know
sensible authors that is flying fully in
the face of all of my expectations what
I'm looking for is some acknowledgment
that it flies completely in the face of
all of my expectation and immediately a
reason why I shouldn't be skeptical even
though it flies in the face of all of my
expectations uh what expectations am I
talking about out while black holes
don't agree that quickly in the ordinary
general relativity in ordinary cosmology
even when matter tries to fall into them
the matter heats up and often gets blown
away rather than falling in uh dark
matter has to literally hit the black
hole exactly on to be absorbed rather
than just orbiting it or something like
that so it's very much not what we would
expect in conventional physics from
black hole Behavior more importantly
like I said we don't think that there is
nearly as much mass and energy in black
holes as in other stuff just from
looking at the black holes and Counting
them and adding up their mass and energy
for them to be the dark energy would
mean that the total amount of energy
density in black holes is much bigger
than the total amount of energy in stars
and gas and everything else that we see
in the universe that just seems wildly
at odd with what we know about the
universe that's not to say that it can't
be right like maybe it's right maybe the
black holes are really tiny or something
like that but then black holes are are
not tied down to space-time they can
move around if the black holes are tiny
enough to evade detection directly they
should still behave like a gas of
non-relativistic particles in other
words like dark matter not like dark
energy they should Clump in galaxies and
clusters they should not be completely
smoothly spread out like ordinary dark
energy is like all of the data say that
dark energy is finally you know this
this is saying the dark energy wasn't
there
um well let me put it this way
if the black holes are growing because
they're accreting energy or Mass from
somewhere from where what happened to
that energy if is it just that there is
some mass and energy that is being
absorbed by the black holes so the black
holes are growing but the energy and
mass and other stuff is going down
equally fast because if so the total
energy density is nothing like dark
energy so it would not be dark energy
like at all anyway maybe all of these
questions have perfectly good answers
but from my reading of the abstract the
title the beginning of the paper there
seems to be no recognition that these
are really big questions that you would
better answer right away you know as
someone who myself has occasionally
written papers that people initially are
going to disagree with I think you know
if I want other people to use their
valuable time to pour through my paper
and try to understand what it is saying
and why it might be right or wrong then
I gotta give them something I got I
gotta give him some reason to do that
that and to me personally these papers
did not give me that reason and you will
notice that even though
the papers got a lot of attention in the
media and on Twitter and whatever it's
not from professional physicists and
cosmologists that are pushing this it's
other sources that are making a big deal
out of this I've not heard any
some any person who I know as a trusted
respected cosmologist who said oh my
goodness yes we've missed this this is
very important and probably the right
answer
if someone does do that then I would
change my credences a little bit but so
far I haven't seen anybody so
I'm very doubtful you know I think that
uh I think it will just probably go away
I would love to be wrong it would be
awesome if something like this were on
the right track I'm just personally a
little skeptical so I haven't done the
work to be skeptical in a more informed
way
Anonymous says if we assume a past
hypothesis how can evidence inform our
estimate of the age of the universe if a
moment of low entropy in the past is a
brute fact a fact worth about a Google
bits of evidence what makes the moment
being 13.7 billion years ago a better
brute fact than the moment being a
trillion years ago or 10 minutes ago
well I think this is a really good
question actually because it's kind of a
subtle answer that I I have a good
degree of confidence in but there's room
for improvement I think what we do in
science in cosmology or any other
science despite some of the
oversimplified versions you might be
sold in high school physics courses or
whatever is a messy back and forth
between constructing models of the
universe and looking at data looking at
information right and the data that
matters to us depends on the theories
that we construct in the models and how
we try to understand the world and we
judge models by various different
criteria including the their Simplicity
and their naturalness in some sense as
well as of course fitting the data
there's absolutely things include other
than in addition to fitting the data
that go into how we judge theories so
the idea of the past hypothesis is that
there is a low entropy beginning to the
observable regime of our universe and so
we identify that with the big bang we're
very very close to the Big Bang about
13.7 billion years ago and we don't know
why people like me try to explain why I
don't think it needs to be a brute fact
to the early Universe had low entropy I
think it can be explicable but right now
we don't agree on what that explanation
is so we take it as a fact the question
is uh what other you know could we
replace that with a different brute fact
and the two options given here are one
trillion years ago or 10 minutes ago and
both have their problems uh a trillion
years ago has the problem that we don't
have any respectable way to
evolve the universe from a trillion
years ago up through the Big Bang to
today again people try people build
models people write down theories people
publish papers but we don't know how to
evolve the universe through the Big Bang
so we keep that as an open question what
happened at the Big Bang whether there
was something before it maybe there was
I'm actually quite
um optimistic I'm optimistic I'm quite
willing to believe that there was
something before the Big Bang but I
don't know it and I don't know what to
do with it we don't have respectable
laws of physics that make that happen so
it is more
legitimate to just say okay some
conditions held near the Big Bang 13.7
billion years ago as far as 10 minutes
ago again that's that actually is
completely plausible yes you could
imagine a brute fact that the Universe
came into existence 10 Bill 10 minutes
ago but you can't just say and it had
low entropy right you need if you want
to fit the data to imagine that the
Universe came into existence 10 minutes
ago looking like we think the universe
looked 10 minutes ago including all of
your memories embedded in your brain Etc
as an enormously complex configuration
of stuff you cannot rule that out on the
basis of data but you can choose to not
take it seriously if you have a better
model if you have a better Theory the
idea the universe began in a hot dense
State rapidly expanding 13.7 billion
years ago with a very low entropy that's
a very simple model you don't need to
specify a whole bunch of individual
people and their brain States or
anything like that and you can plausibly
evolve from that to the universe we see
today so there's all sorts of things
that are possible if you're gonna if you
want to ask like you know could this
theory of the universe be possible but
we're looking for the best theory of the
universe and the best theory we have
right now is for whatever reason the
universe 13.7 billion years ago was a
hot dense low entropy rapidly expanding
state
Eric fast says well I'm not a relativist
about morality I find relativism about
meaning much more compelling if someone
chooses to dedicate their life to
something I find uninteresting or even
absurd who am I to say they should do
something else on the other hand compare
a life spent doing something
conventionally meaningful raising a
family pursuing an ambitious career
making lasting contributions to arts or
science to a lifespan doing nothing but
watching reality TV we would like to be
able to say that one is more meaningful
than the other and not just in a
subjective sense do you think
constructivism applies here can we
construct a theory of meaning and then
judge those who fail to meet our
standards for a meaningful life or
should we be relativists and accept that
meaning in life is completely subjective
for me personally I think this is again
a very good question I think it's a it's
a nice way of framing the issue and I
fall on the side of more or less being a
relativist about meaning uh I don't
think that someone who sits in front of
the TV all day watching reality TV
um is making a mistake in any objective
sense or even acting in such a way that
I personally have the right to judge
them
it's I can say that I personally would
not want to do that right that's not my
favorite lifestyle I think that the
reason why it's interesting to think
about meaning in life as we have done
very recently here on the podcast
um is not because we want to judge other
people for getting it wrong but because
we want to do it for ourselves
meaningfulness in this sense uh if if
we're agreeing what we mean when we talk
about meaning in life it's a more
personal individual Choice it doesn't
affect other people in the same way when
we get to the question of whether or not
sitting in front of your TV all day
makes other people's lives worse then
now you're talking about morality right
or ethics or communal living living in a
society that's not a question of meaning
in life meaning in life tends to be very
personal and therefore to me is
completely relativistic I don't think
that there's any objective answers but
it's still interesting to talk about
because even if I say meaning in life is
is relative I'm able to come up with it
myself that doesn't tell me how to come
up with it right there's still a lot of
work to be done like you know what what
gives my life meaning how do I attach
meaning to it as a personal question can
be a very hard one that's why we debate
different possibilities that's why I
think we should be open to inspiration
from many different sources and take the
best of what we hear from all sorts of
things whether it's religious texts or
fiction or movies or our friends or our
inner contemplations or whatever it is
whatever thoughts can lead you to a life
that you personally find more meaningful
good for you that's great
Jeff B says can you talk about why the
Schrodinger equation needs to be complex
valued and why the phase is important
understanding how a wave function
behaves
so it's not the Schrodinger equation
technically that needs to be complex
valued it is the wave function the
quantum State uh the easiest way to
represent the quantum state of a system
is as a vector in a Hilbert space a
complex Vector Space by complex Vector
space we mean Vector space is just
something where you have a bunch of
elements and you can add them together
and you can scale them by multiplying by
some numbers right you can make a vector
longer or shorter by multiplying it by a
number and in the case of a complex
Vector space you're allowed to multiply
by complex numbers real plus imaginary
part numbers and you know you don't
actually ever have to use complex
numbers you can always rephrase complex
things in terms of real things if I say
that I have a complex number A plus I B
where A and B are real numbers and I is
the square root of minus one then I can
always just use new notation where
rewrite everything in terms of A and B
and some rules for multiplying them
together and so forth uh it's awkward
it's just not very nice it's not very
elegant it's just much easier to bite
the bullet and use those complex numbers
so that's what we do but like many other
mathematical things it's a choice based
on convenience so the real question is
sort of how why is that the most
convenient thing why does quantum
mechanics make complex numbers the most
convenient thing and people have tried
to answer this question uh but I kind of
think that it's the kind of question
that might never have a completely
satisfactory answer because what kind of
answer could you possibly get right
you're going to say well the reason why
the wave function is complex is because
dot dot dot and then you're going to
invoke some other principle or fact that
you want to be true Stephen Hawking
wrote a paper about this actually and he
had you know something based on time
Symmetry and path integrals and stuff
like that that eventually led him to say
and that's why the wave function has to
be complex
but you're invoking those other things
right you're assuming some other things
that then lead you to say that the wave
function is complex in the way that I
like just like like to think about
quantum mechanics the complexity of the
wave function is simply the starting
point right it's the first ingredient
one of the first ingredients you put in
Quantum states are represented by
vectors in a complex Vector space that's
one of the beginning points so in the
axioms of quantum mechanics so I don't
try to explain it it has consequences
for example the wave function can evolve
uh let's say you have a wave function
that a vector that is of unit length
right so its length is one that's what a
good wave function does and then you
sort of take the components and you can
square them to get the probabilities so
they will add up to one
just by Pythagoras's Theorem right and
but you want it to evolve without
changing the fact that its length is one
you know if you think of a wave an
individual wave oscillating up and down
it can oscillate up and down but that
means it has to go through zero if you
have a real valued number that goes
between -1 and plus one it goes through
zero on the way but a complex number can
oscillate from -1 to plus one without
going through zero it's its magnitude
can stay equal to one by going e to the
I Omega T where Omega is the frequency
and T is time so that's basically saying
you go from -1 to I to plus one to minus
I to minus one Etc and that turns out to
be extremely useful for what actually
happens in Quantum Mechanics for
interference effects that maintain the
probability rule all that stuff so the
fact that the wave function is complex
is very important in quantum mechanics
or that it's conveniently represented
using complex numbers is very important
but I just I'm happy to just take it as
true and uh go from there if you prefer
something else that you want to use to
derive it that's also okay one of the
things about axiomatic systems is
there's often different ways to write
down the fundamental axioms and derive
them from each other
I'm going to group two questions
together one is from John Morgan who
says in a prior AMA you mentioned that
should human lifetimes be extended
indefinitely you feel like you've got a
good several thousand years of things to
keep you occupied and interested in
staying alive so assuming at one point
you'd undertake a distinctly different
career what would be your first next gig
and Paul Hess says do you imagine a face
of your life where research will not be
a central activity around which all of
your other activities orbit last month's
AMA question about a life of thousands
or more years got me thinking about how
some of us seem to wholeheartedly become
different people in different phases of
our life While others seem to be the
same core person with the same basic
habits as they travel through different
parts of their lives I don't think
either of these two is better or worse
or even as pure as described but I would
love to hear your own self-concept of
how you might change over the years
so that's a it is a good question that I
have not really put a lot of thought
into on the basis of assuming that my
life will probably not last thousands of
years
um I do feel very much in favor of this
idea that your life should change again
now we're talking about a meaningful
life in a very personal sense so when I
say I think your life should change what
I really mean is I think my life should
change you can do whatever you want
that's fine as long as long as you're
happy and fulfilled but I do think that
I enjoy doing different things at
different phases of my life having said
that obviously I'm not doing radically
different things I've been you know
sticking around universities basically
my whole adult life so I'm not uh
completely flipped things over and
changed things within the university
I've changed specific things that I do
but I'm not you know suddenly taking to
see in a sailboat or anything like that
um if I did think that I was going to
last for thousands of years and be you
know healthy and aware the whole time I
could easily see doing something very
very very different but I guess sorry I
should I should remove the words very
very from that statement I could easily
see doing something different but the
kinds of things that I would see myself
doing are arguably in the same kind of
universe the same universe of trying to
be creative and intellectual and learn
about the world and understand the world
I mean I could easily see being a
history Professor or something like that
right
um something slightly different would be
uh more in the creative arts kind of
thing the Arts rather than the Sciences
whether it be writing fiction which is
probably the easiest transition I could
imagine
music is something that I really like
but I'm terrible at so I don't think I
could make a very much of a career doing
that or acting for that matter likewise
uh but who knows if I knew I had
thousands of years to practice maybe I
could become better at it so I think
that you know if I had a guaranteed
thousands of years lifespan I would like
to sort of do a journey through various
different ways of thinking about the
world learning about it creating new
things that would be my very vague road
map for what actually happens but you
know on the other hand maybe I'll just
end up playing poker and making money
that way
Jim Murphy says I'm reading Quantum
field Theory as simply as possible by
Tony Z in one dimension the concept of a
wave packet being produced makes perfect
sense to me since it's just like a
little signal traveling down a wire but
when we move to two Dimensions I don't
see how wave packets could be produced
thinking about the surface of water for
example when a pebble gets thrown into a
pond the ripples spread out in all
directions I don't see where in all this
the packets get produced or in 3D when
you scream the sound gets spread out in
all directions
so there is a new book that just came
out by uh Anthony Z my former colleague
at the itpe in Santa Barbara who is a
very respected well-known theoretical
physicist and also the author of a bunch
of very good books including a
standard not really standard because
he's a quirky writer but a more or less
straightforward Quantum field Theory
textbook and Tony has a new book out
called Quantum field Theory as simply as
possible which at first when I saw it I
got a little worried because it was
uncomfortably close to what I'm trying
to do in volume 2 of the biggest ideas
in the universe explain Quantum field
Theory to a broad audience but then I
actually bought it and looked at it and
my my worry went away not because it's
not good or or worth reading but because
his approach is so completely different
to mine that there's essentially no
worry that there's going to be overlap
there for one thing his book is way
longer than mine would be and even
though you know he does work very hard
to not overload you with equations Etc
he is going through sort of the standard
curriculum that you would learn to do
Quantum field Theory whereas I'm trying
very hard to reimagine things so that
you can get the essence of quantum field
Theory without it just being a quick and
dirty version of a standard Quantum
field Theory course anyway I recommend
the book very much if you want to check
it out while you're still waiting for
volume two of the biggest ideas to come
out so
the question is about wave packets and I
think this is a very good question to
ask and I might give you a different
answer than you get elsewhere so feel
free to ask other physicists to do a
reality check here
um I think that Jim your intuition is
completely correct generally in the
world of wave phenomena when you clap
your hands and sound comes out or when
you throw a pebble into a pond and it
ripples those waves move out in all
directions that generally is what
happens and it also happens in Quantum
field Theory or in quantum mechanics and
then we have this question why is it
that what we observe looks like
particles leaving tracks that look like
trajectories not big puffy waves moving
out in all directions of course you know
the answer to that it is because the
particles are interacting and decohering
and you're seeing part of the wave
function and you can actually do a
calculation that is that says if you
have a spherically expanding wave
function and you put it in something
like a bubble chamber or a cloud chamber
right these are detection apparatuses
that can let you see the track of a
little charged particle moving through
them well very quickly the wave function
bumps into this Cloud chamber that
you're in and it is essentially measured
right it decoheres the universe branches
the wave function branches into many
different branches Each of which
describes the particle having bumped
into the cloud chamber at some
particular point with some particular
momentum and then if you follow the
subsequent Evolution that little point
with a certain momentum is moving along
more or less the straight line that you
see in the cloud chamber or a curved
line if you're in a magnetic field
so I think that the answer to your
question is the real world almost never
has wave packets freely moving in empty
space the real world has these big
spherical waves like when you I think
this is an accurate statement when you
detect a photon From A Distant star or
Galaxy
before you detected it its wave function
was spread out over millions or billions
of light years and you just collapsed
that wave function by detecting it and
you're like well that seems a little
lucky that I had collapsed right down to
me but there's a whole bunch of other
wave functions which you're not
detecting which will eventually be
detected as moving in some other
direction so it all bounces out in the
end the wave packet idea is a convenient
fiction for Quantum field theorists you
can convince yourself or let yourself
believe that Quantum fields are acting
particle-like by pointing out correctly
that I can always construct a little
vibration in a Quantum field that is
confined to a small region that looks
like a little packet and that kind of
Acts particle-like but you're right that
doesn't automatically happen it's sort
of temporarily happens while things are
being observed and that's why we see
tracks in detectors and things like that
but out there in empty space the waves
move out in all directions
David Maxwell says imagine you wake up
tomorrow and you are 40 light years from
Earth alone with no chance of company
but with ready access to the entirety of
human writings medical technology that
will keep you alive to 120 and the
ability to send messages back to Earth
with no faster than light trickery how
do you spend the rest of your life so I
had to like parse this question to see
exactly what David was getting out
getting at here
um I think that what is it what is being
gotten at here is in this circumstance
where I have I'm healthy I'm good
medical technology and ready access to
the entirety of human writings I could
continue to write I guess podcast you
know the question just said send
messages back to Earth I can't interview
anybody though so it'd be nothing but
solo podcasts but I could continue to
write I could write books and things
like that I could do research in some
sense I'm not sure if my ready access to
the entirety of human writings gets
updated probably not it's probably
probably just the right the access to
the entirety human writings as of the
moment that I appeared the question then
is would I think two questions one is
would I think I have anything
interesting to say so one thing is of
course I would because suddenly I woke
up tomorrow 40 light years away that's a
that's a very interesting story to tell
I want to think about that and then
later on the question says there's no
fashion like trickery I'm not how we I'm
not sure how we can reconcile those two
ideas but there are things I would still
want to say I guess the the flip side of
that is I would never know what people
thought about what I was writing right
there'd be no comment section there'd be
no sales figures there'd be no talk that
I gave with questions and answers
afterward or letters or anything like
that would it still be worth doing
research writing Etc if I felt that I
could send my work back to Earth but I
never knew what the response was
I think the response would I think that
you would get a lot of readership
because you're stuck 40 light years away
that's a pretty unique thing unless
there's a whole bunch of better writers
than me that are also stuck 40 light
years away
um so I think that I would still you
know write I would still try to think of
things and write them down and you know
maybe be better if you didn't know what
people thought about your work it's
obviously overall worse because you
don't get constructive feedback but
maybe there's a little bit of more of
less worry about the less constructive
feedback that sometimes you get so uh
otherwise are there other things I would
do yeah you know
um I would I would uh amuse myself in
some way maybe I would finally learn to
play some musical instrument I'm not
sure
Sid Huff says I understand that the U.S
National Institutes of Health has
tentatively planned to stop using
measures of researchers expertise and
their institutions as part of Grant
evaluations supposedly this is to reduce
reputation bias and Grant decision
making do you think this is an
appropriate step to take and if so would
you approve the National Science
Foundation adopting the same measure for
physics grants so let me personally say
I have no idea why this is true or not
that the NIH is doing this this is just
a an assumption embedded into the
question and I would say no I do not
think this is a good idea there are
certainly it was amusing to me when I
first realized that philosophy papers
you know technical Journal research
papers are most often reviewed blindly
in other words you if you're the
reviewer which I've been a reviewer for
some of these papers you're not told who
the author is or where they are you're
just given the paper if you want to
cheat in the modern world you can very
often Google the title or the abstract
or whatever but I found it's actually a
really useful
exercise do not do that to you know take
it seriously and sometimes you you
probably can't right like not everyone
puts their papers online some people do
some people don't uh it's it's good for
the soul to actually read the paper
without any idea who the person is and
what they're getting at and one thing
you find is that sometimes people are
not very good at making clear what
they're getting at and sometimes it'll
be useful to know oh I know what this
person is getting at because they've
been getting at this for the last 40
years
um
I don't know if it'd work for physics
papers and it all it barely works for
philosophy papers honestly but I get I
think it's a good motivation you know
the aspiration is in the right direction
I don't think that's true for Grant
proposals in fact I would say the
opposite should be true you know one of
the things I've long thought is that
there should be basically two kinds of
funding that funding agencies do one
kind is
how good has your research been if it's
been good we'll give you money you don't
even have to send in a proposal like if
you want money and your research has
been good we will give you the money
because you're a good researcher and
then maybe you know you get renewed
every three years and if in those three
years you didn't do anything you get a
warning you know the funding agency says
we sure hope you're really cooking up a
blockbuster there because you haven't
done anything for the last three years
and in the next three years if you still
don't do anything you're cut off
but maybe you've taken the time to
actually do a blockbuster which is hard
to do the current system where you have
to pretend to you know as a theoretical
physicist there's a ongoing joke a
long-running joke about theoretical
physicists writing Grand proposals
because the grand proposals always want
you to explain exactly what you're going
to do
if you're building an experiment or
doing observations that's a possible ask
you can tell what your plan to build is
if you're a theoretical physicist you
have no idea what you're actually going
to do for the next three years you can
say I'm interested in these problems but
if you knew how to solve them you would
have solved them already so very often
you end up kind of lying you basically
take what you have most recently done
and pretend to have not done it yet and
say I plan to do this and then you can
be very specific about what you plan to
do because you've already done it and
there's this weird Kabuki theater back
and forth that people go through and
it's a tremendous waste of time people
put a lot of effort into writing Grant
proposals the acceptance rate is not
very good if there's someone who has
clearly been doing super good work for
over a decade why are you putting them
through this pretending that they're
gonna do something that either they've
already done or they're just guessing at
it's just a complete waste of very very
very valuable resources in my mind so I
think that established researchers
should be able to just get money on the
basis that they have been doing good
work
without trying to guess what they're
going to do next and then there should
be another track right that's one track
the other track is you're not
established or you're an established
researcher but you're planning to do
something completely different right so
new territory grants and there it would
make perfect sense to get rid of
information about expertise or
institution or anything like that
because you're really proposing I would
like to do this new thing and maybe it's
because you're young and it's the first
thing you've ever done maybe it's
because you're older and you're trying
to do something new but in any way
you're not being
evaluated on your reason accomplishments
you're being evaluated on the cogency of
your proposal that's a different kind of
thing and I think that's also very good
but it shouldn't be the only thing I
will say you know for the cynics out
there I've sat on Plenty of Grant review
committees right where you for the doe
the department of energy or for the
National Science Foundation uh for the
Guggenheim Foundation or whatever you
read these proposals and you decide who
to give money to and in my experience uh
there's been plenty of very high
reputation people who did not get
funding from the Committees I was on
because they had kind of phoned it in in
their Grant proposal right and I felt
kind of guilty about it because
I bet they will do good work and they
probably deserve money to do it but
given the criteria we were given they
their proposals were not as good as some
young unknown person and so the young
unknown person got the money and that I
think that the people who have not been
in that situation being on the grant
Review Committee probably underestimate
the seriousness of how people who are on
those committees really addressed their
task I've heard similar things about
juries you know in criminal procedures
you know people are always surprised
that the the people who are sitting on
the jury actually take their job really
seriously and they you know once you're
in that situation it's kind of an
argument for sortition as a way to pass
legislation like once you're in that
position of responsibility you actually
kind of
try your best you know whatever that is
maybe your best isn't that great but you
try your best to be free of bias
Etc
um so I I don't think that that
particular move on the NIH is part
sounds very promising to me no
David Harper says as a professor do you
think the student as customer mentality
is a real thing at universities and do
you think it could possibly be a good
thing what onus should be placed on
students
you know I am not an expert in
educational policy or the current
American University
Etc so I can only talk about my own
personal experience and my own personal
experience is I've never seen that
philosophy that mentality at all none of
the places I've been have thought of
their students as customers
um and you know in fact I I don't know
what I don't know how people
Envision what actually happens in
universities but to a very large extent
faculty members do whatever they want
you know faculty members teach the
courses they want uh or at least you
know maybe the department which is their
other faculty members assigns them
certain courses to teach but they do so
using the texts that they want giving
the exams that they want handing out the
grades they want Etc there's always one
or two stories that get attention of
like oh this person was fired because
they're a tough grader or something like
that but or or you know and on the other
side of things like these people were
giving passing grades to all the players
on the basketball team or the football
team or something like that so there's
these stories about that but it's very
very far away from representative of
what typically happens you know I've
been teaching courses I've taught two
courses last semester no one in my
department knows what grades I gave or
what texts or anything like that the
faculty individual faculty have enormous
autonomy in this in this kind of
situation so I don't know I don't know
what impact it has had other places on
other people Etc
I look at the relationship between
students and faculty as kind of a
complicated nuanced thing the students
are paying to get an education and
they're sort of putting the
responsibility in the hands of the
professors to put them in a position to
get that education and at the end of the
day it's the student's responsibility to
take advantage of that position that
they're put in you cannot force people
to learn uh some people like why do
people cheat right if if you thought
that the goal of being at a university
was to be educated to learn things
cheating on exams or papers is
completely counterproductive you are not
forcing yourself to learn the things
that you learn of course there are many
many students whose goal at University
is not to get an education but to get a
credential they want to go to medical
school or law school or just get a job
or whatever fortunately for me those
students are not ones that I interact
with very much maybe there are different
parts of the University where they're
all over the place but then you'd have
to talk to someone in that position I
really can't say
David Dubrow says why is it that a book
always seems to be used as the
quintessential example object thrown
into a black hole when discussing the
black hole information Paradox it seems
to me that the content of a book has
relatively little information compared
to the book itself as an object with a
very specific structure irrespective of
the actual ink mark on its pages
yes of course you're completely correct
we could throw anything at all into the
black hole and the point is you know how
what is a complete specification of the
quantum state of the thing you're
throwing in that's the information that
is relevant in that sense the difference
between a book with blank pages and a
book with text on it is infinitesimally
Tiny in terms of how much information
content there is but it's an example
like you said writing the question it's
the quintessential example object no one
is really throwing things into black
holes we're using examples to drive home
the idea that information exists it's
going into the black hole how do you get
it out it's easier for the typical
person who is not a scientist to
Envision the existence of information as
the text on the pages of the book then
the complete Quantum state of all the
atoms and molecules of which the book is
made technically is the latter that
really matters but the former also
matters and it's a more Vivid example so
we generally use that
noble gas says has Lo Schmidt's Paradox
been resolved to your satisfaction if so
briefly explain how probably should have
put this one earlier when we were
talking about the past hypothesis but
loshmi's Paradox I mean you can really
read all about this in my book from
eternity to here if you want both the
history of it and the resolution
loshmit's reversibility puzzle as I
would like to call it was a challenge to
boltzmann when boltzmann was trying to
First explain the second law of
Thermodynamics and entropy in terms of
Arrangements of atoms right
we already knew about entropying that
was clausius and Carno before him uh but
boltzmann and Maxwell and others came up
with a definition an understanding of
what entropy is in a world where things
are made of atoms namely the entropy is
a way of measuring how many different
Arrangements of the atoms there are that
satisfy certain macroscopic criteria
maybe what you see when you look at it
or something like that and boltzmann
basically said entropy tends to increase
because there are far more ways to be
high entropy than to be low entropy so
if you start in a low entropy
configuration the overwhelming majority
of trajectories will take you to a
higher entropy configuration and lo
Schmidt who is actually Boltzmann's old
Professor from his university days
pointed out completely correctly that
that can't be the entire answer because
the you're sneakily asking the question
if you begin with low entropy what is
likely to happen but you're not at but
you could be asking the question of all
the trajectories in the universe not
conditionalizing on starting at low
entry but of all the trajectories what
is likely to happen and the answer there
because the underlying laws of physics
are presumed to be reversible the
chances that you will start in high
entropy and spontaneously move down to
lower entropy in apparent contradiction
to the second law of Thermodynamics are
exactly as big as the chances that you
would have started randomly in the low
entropy state to start with said another
much more simpler way there's a
precisely equal number of trajectories
going from low entropy to high as going
from high entropy to low it has to be
that way because the laws of physics are
present to be reversible that's low
Schmidt's reversibility Paradox and it's
a one of many different versions of the
idea that you cannot start with time
symmetric laws and derive time
asymmetric Behavior so the resolution is
you need to put in something time
asymmetric and the answer is you put in
the assumption that the early Universe
started with low entropy
that's the past hypothesis that we
started the whole AMA talking about the
past hypothesis is
a Time non-symmetric assumption about
low entropy at initial conditions and
there is no analogous high end there's
no analogous Assumption of any sort for
the future it's only the past hypothesis
there's no future hypothesis so that
breaks the Symmetry and resolves the
paradox
Casey Mahone says do you have any
mindless or repetitive Hobbies you use
to help you relax for instance I enjoy
knitting
it depends what you mean by Mindless and
repetitive
um you know probably the closest thy
would come is just playing mindless
repetitive games on the iPad for a few
minutes before going to bed at night or
whatever right Solitaire or poker or
backgammon or you know very simple
things that have nothing to do with
whatever it is I've been thinking about
in research or book writing or
podcasting for the day but I wouldn't
even raise those to the level of a hobby
I don't really think about it that much
so probably the answer is no in the in
the conception that you have in mind
there
Brendan says do you think the difference
between being agnostic and being an
atheist comes down to the probability
one gives in there being a God I know
you and other carefully thinking
atheists acknowledge there is a very low
probability of God existing but still
are okay with using the term atheist
instead of agnostic
so I don't you know I don't want to
worry too much about arguing about the
definitions of these words like we
should agree on definitions and then
argue about substance rather than
arguing about definitions roughly
speaking atheists are people who think
that they are confident enough to say
that God doesn't exist that doesn't mean
it's with 100 metaphysical certainty I
can't say anything with 100 metaphysical
certainty but if I look outside and I
say it's not raining I could be fooled I
could there could be evil demons I'm
going to put a screen outside my window
that is tricking me or something like
that so I'm not 100 sure but I'm not
going to include all of those caveats in
my state but I'm just going to say yeah
it is not raining right now and I mean
that at some confidence level 0.99
whatever and I have exactly the same
feeling about the existence of God
agnostics would like to say that we just
don't have enough information one way or
the other so I will not pass judgment on
whether or not God exists and roughly
speaking that probably corresponds to a
Credence in God existing that is bigger
than 0.0001 but smaller than 0.99
something okay but you know I do think
that there is but but there's that's the
respectable way of doing it so I think
that having a Credence in the existence
of God whatever it is is a perfectly
respectable thing to do
there is a strategy sometimes used by
agnostics that I think is not reasonable
which is to somehow carve out the
existence of God as a question that is
somehow a different kind of question
than whether it is raining outside right
now to say that the existence of God is
something that we can't have evidence
for or against therefore I shouldn't
have any high or low Credence in it
being true I think that's just wrong I
think that's just mistaking how we
generally come to our credences uh as I
alluded to before science is a tricky
kind of subtle process of going back and
forth between model building and
evidence and even if you don't have
direct evidence for or against the
existence of God you can still evaluate
that claim on the basis of perfectly
ordinary scientific reasoning that's a
theory about the nature of the universe
the existence of God how does it fit the
data in and if that theory were true
would you expect the universe to look
that way if that word not true how would
you expect the universe to look plugin
bases theorem all the ordinary things so
the kind of agnostic reasoning that
somehow tries to treat the existence of
God differently than other big questions
about the Universe I think is
wrong-headed I think it's it's treating
God you know as a different category
than the question really belongs to be
in
um and therefore I would I would argue
against that I think that's not just a
matter of personal credences I think
that's a logical mistake there
Ali Whittle says my six-year-old son and
I listening to your like listening to
your amas while driving he has the
following question I understand that
black holes suck everything in but what
is a white hole what does it push out
Emerson Whittle aged six so thank you
Emerson I enjoy uh your question I'm
glad you were able to ask it uh I hope
it's not you who are driving I hope it's
your uh father Ali who's doing the
driving while you're listening to this
so first it's not precisely exactly true
that black holes suck everything in and
this is you know an opportunity to sort
of get this right black holes are
regions of space-time that have a
gravitational field so you can orbit
them like you can orbit the sun Etc and
they have the feature that if you enter
that region you can never leave okay you
don't have to enter that region you can
literally just stay orbiting the black
hole so the Earth is orbiting the Sun
right now if tomorrow we took all the
mass of the Sun and squeezed it down and
made a black hole the Earth would still
orbit in precisely the same way it would
not get sucked in so it's better to say
that black holes are one way you can go
in but not come out rather than
imagining some sucking force that is
different than the ordinary force of
gravity it's just ordinary gravity in
action here a white hole is completely
hypothetical we have no evidence that
white holes exist but technically
speaking a white hole is just a black
hole cool played backward in time so if
you imagine making a black hole by some
reasonable physical process like a large
star reaches the end of its life its
fuel gives out it collapses and it makes
a black hole okay you could imagine
playing that entire process backward in
time you would start with a white hole
it would throw out all the matter and
energy that would make a star and then
you'd get us have a star there now
that's implausible for all sorts of
reasons it is literally violating the
reversibility of time right or you know
it is sorry it is only possible if you
think the time is reversible but
macroscopically in the real world it is
not there is an arrow of time for white
holes to exist entropy has to be able to
go down which it's not that never ever
actually happens in the real world so I
think that the right way to think about
white holes are as hypothetical
mathematical constructions but nothing
you need to worry about existing in the
real world the one little exception to
that is that in some sense our whole
universe is kind of like a white hole it
started with a singularity and at least
that's the prediction of classical
general relativity the Big Bang
Singularity is kind of like the past
Singularity of a white hole the time
reverse of a future singularity in a
black hole but there's no outside golden
to which we're being spit out so the
analogy to a white hole is not perfect
even for the universe as a whole
Josh Charles says I it blew my mind when
I learned that the information in a
black hole is proportional to its
surface area and not its volume my
intuition wants to interpret this as a
changing of the geometry of space-time
such that it doesn't have a volume if
space is emergent is it possible that
this is indicative of such a modulation
and if not would it be possible to have
multiple geometries of space-time within
the same universe
I'm not sure I'm going to give a
satisfactory answer to this question but
I'll try to say some true or at least
plausible things that might help you
think about it yourself
um
you know first when people say the
information in a black hole is
proportional to its surface area that's
a way of talking about the fact that the
entropy of a black hole is proportionals
to its surface area that's really what
is going on and by itself that wouldn't
be weird at all if you just have
um an ordinary condensed matter system
by condensed matter I mean something we
literally make out of you know atoms and
molecules and and you put it in a
lattice okay so you have like some
two-dimensional sheet of graphene or
spins or something like that okay and
you put that condensed matter system
that two-dimensional sheet into its
lowest energy state so it's in its
vacuum State there's nothing going on
but there are there's a Quantum State
and there are atoms and molecules and
they can be entangled with each other
and whatever okay this is a very typical
thing the condensed matter physicists
look at in the lab and you consider some
subsystem so you take this
two-dimensional sheet and you like in
your mind and not with a knife but in
your mind you carve out a little region
okay and and like I said the atoms and
the quantum degrees of freedom in that
region can be entangled with the region
with the atoms outside that region and
therefore that region has an entropy and
guess what the entropy of that region is
going to be proportional to the area of
the region that you just cut out why
because the entanglement is mostly
short-ranged atoms are going to be
highly entangled with ones nearby not so
entangled with ones far away and so all
the entanglement that you're breaking by
cutting out the region is located near
the boundary and the area of the
boundary gives you the total amount of
broken entanglement and therefore the
total amount of entropy so that's a
long-winded way of saying the fact that
the entropy of something is proportional
to its area not its volume is not
surprising we absolutely have very
ordinary
non-gravitational non-black hole
examples of that what makes it
surprising it's not really surprising at
all but what makes it surprising in the
black hole case is that it's supposed to
be a maximum entropy configuration
you're not supposed to be able to and I
think it's true you can't fit more
entropy into any region of space than a
black hole has
that's surprising because if you take
our condensed matter system remember I
said it was in its lowest energy state
but its lowest energy state is not its
maximum entropy state right if you heat
it up you can get a lot more entropy in
that system and in that case the maximum
entropy that you can have in the region
that you cut out is proportional to its
volume
so the weird back and forth is if
something is in its vacuum State it's
very natural for a subsystem to have an
entropy proportional to area if it's in
its maximum entropy State you'd expect
it to have an entropy proportional to
volume a black hole is a maxim entropy
state but it still has an entropy
proportional to area not to volume okay
that is the very complex back and forth
but pretty respectable uh set of
intuitions that we might have about this
and this is what led people to invent
the holographic principle Leonard suskin
and Jordan tuft and others the idea that
all of the information is somehow
literally on the horizon of the black
hole or at least can be thought of as
being there okay all that is background
to the actual question
um Josh wants to interpret this as a
changing of the geometry of space-time
such that it doesn't have a volume well
you know we don't we don't know what was
the first thing to say we're speculating
here we've never been close to a black
hole much less inside it doing delicate
experiments or anything like that so
everything I say is conjectural here but
what you're conjecturing is something
very similar to the principle not of
holography but of black hole
complementarity this is another idea
that came from suskin and others and the
complementarity idea is that
what the black hole is
the physical system that you should
think of as the black hole depends on
how you look at it there is a way of
looking at the black hole which you can
roughly associate with someone falling
into it
and there it looks like a
three-dimensional region of space
four-dimensional region of space time
with the volume and everything is
completely normal when you're inside
except you're going to be crushed in the
future okay whereas from the point of
view of the outside Observer and that
that initial in following point of view
is what we would learn about in our
classical general relativity textbook
that's what Einstein's equation would
teach you about
would seem to imply but the
complementarity idea is that from the
perspective of an outside Observer it is
as if the Horizon of the black hole is
the black hole that all of what is
happening in the black hole can be
thought of as living on a membrane the
classical version of this is called the
membrane Paradigm this is sort of the
quantum mechanical version of it the
complementarity idea that they're from
the point of view an outside Observer a
black hole is a membrane with a certain
area and a certain number of degrees of
freedom
if that's what you mean by saying
there's a changing of the geometry is
Phase time then yes that is what is
going on multiple geometries of space
time in the same universe yes but again
it's the it's a very careful statement
the black you can't say the black hole
is three-dimensional or two-dimensional
it appears one way or the other two
different observers or from different
perspectives it is some Quantum state
right the that's the essence of it at
the end of the day so geometries of
space time emerge out of that from some
certain perspective that you're looking
at
tarun says in your book something deeply
hidden you describe how Schrodinger's
Cat being either dead or alive would
rapidly decohere into two branches due
to interactions with the environment
before the Observer has even looked
inside but if the purpose of the box is
in a sense to avoid any interaction with
the environment even if that's not
possible in practice wouldn't the cat
indeed be in a superposition of States
as far as the outside world is concerned
until the box is opened well
I think the short answer there is it's
difficult you know even like you say
even if it's not possible in practice
but practice matters for these questions
it is really not possible in practice
like the environment in the box is
literally like the air and the photons
in the Box okay so you'll only have a
dead cat if there's no air in the box so
that's a that's a problematic thing but
even if you forget about that even if
you somehow imagine that the cat stays
alive even though there's no air there a
cat gives off radiation right a cat is
you know has a body temperature that
gives off infrared light and instantly
the nanosecond after you start the
experiment there's an environment
because the cat has given off radiation
differently depending on whether it's in
one position or the other all of which
is to say the whole point is once you
get a system that is as macroscopic and
messy and high temperature as a cat it
is really really really really really
hard to avoid it interacting with an
environment and branching the wave
function so hard that it never happens
and you know the point of
decoherence and the many worlds
interpretation is to explain what
actually happens that's why in David not
David Lewis David Wallace's book about
many worlds it's called the emergent
Multiverse because it is emergent you
can always just talk about the wave
function and avoid branching just like
you can always talk about the gas in the
rooms being a bunch of atoms and
molecules it's way more convenient to
talk at a higher level of description
where there's smaller number of entities
that you're concerned with and at that
higher level there are branches of the
wave function so we're actually trying
to solve in practice problems here to
just so to say well this is not possible
in practice means who who cares that
that's not what we're interested here
when we do the many worlds
interpretation if you are super
interested in things that are not
possible in practice then I would just
say just have this Schrodinger equation
just solve it don't ever talk about
branches your laplace's demon
congratulations
Malta uble says the other day my
daughter six was complaining over
breakfast that sometimes when the
teacher called on her she'd not always
know the answer to their question I
somewhat unhelpfully quipped if in doubt
just answer your teacher with that is
because of the second law of
Thermodynamics but then my wife dropped
in that isn't right for math questions
which is very fair my question is which
classes of answers do not have the
second law of Thermodynamics somewhere
in their causal chain
I think that I could be cheeky and try
to claim that every question does
because someone came up with a question
and that person who came up with it is
embedded in the second law of
Thermodynamics but I get the point of
the question I think the simple answer
is does the issue being addressed have
time reversibility is the answer the
same whether you run it forward or
backward in time you know even math
questions have an element of
interestingness to their reversibility
that's the whole basis of the fact of uh
P versus NP and and prime numbers right
to prime factor a big number is
difficult to take a big number and
discover his prime factors is difficult
but to start with some prime factors and
multiply them together is easy right so
doing it one way in time is actually
easier than doing it the other way of
time but of course you can do it either
way and the actual
for either multiplying or factoring you
can do those things either forward or
backward in time so it's not technically
time that is getting in there so I would
just say you know think in the back of
your mind could I do exactly the same
thing backward in time and would it look
weird would it require you know would
someone notice if I did this and I made
a movie of it and I played the movie
backward would people notice that
something funny was going on if so then
the second law of Thermodynamics is
definitely playing a role there
Chris Shipton says is it possible to
slow the spin of a black hole down from
the podcast that mentions spitting black
holes it seems like the spin always
increases when something is thrown into
the black hole Yeah it's absolutely
possible I mean the spin of a black hole
has a direction there's an angular
momentum and you just throw something in
moving the other way
in other words for real black holes
generally the stuff that is falling in
is in the form of an accretion disk and
that disc is rotating in the same
direction as the black hole is so the
black hole gets more angular momentum
when that stuff Falls in but if by hand
you just threw something in in the other
direction it would absolutely slow down
the spin of the black hole in fact
that's exactly what happens in the
Penrose process the Penrose process
named after Roger Penrose former
mindscape cast is a way of extracting
energy from spinning black holes by
slowing down their spin
Simon Carter says I was re-listening to
your Christmas message from a few years
ago titled the screwy Universe we were
talking about birefringence and
mentioned an experiment had confirmed
this to two Sigma and you were waiting
to see if further details would either
rule it out or further confirm has there
been any further update over the last
few years
yeah this is something that takes time
there have been updates but they're very
slow and tentative there's still updates
in the sense of analyzing the existing
data but try to do better better data
and Analysis yeah analyzes of it
um and my impression I have not followed
this super duper carefully but my
impression is two things the claimed
detection is still there maybe it's even
arguably closer to three sigma than 2 2
Sigma it's a small detection it's saying
that so for those of sorry for those of
you who don't know
what we're talking about is the
possibility that light polarized light
as it travels through empty space over
Cosmic distances has its polarization
Vector rotated a little bit and what
we're talking about here is literally a
third of a degree as it goes from the
cosmic microwave background to us so a
very tiny amount of rotation and this is
an effect that you would not expect to
see in ordinary physics you can get
rotation of polarization that's very
easy Faraday rotation is an example but
that has a very clear signature because
the amount of rotation depends on the
wavelength of the light and
my first ever published paper with
George field and Roman Jacob uh looked
at how to constrain theories of
electromagnetism which violated Lorenzen
variants which picked out a preferred
Direction in the universe in space-time
and the particular thing that we looked
at was a very easy straightforward way
of violating the rents and variants and
it predicted Cosmic by refringence and I
typed in some data and fit some numbers
and did some least squares and showed
that it was consistent with zero by
refringence in the real world but you
know our limits were like 10 degrees of
rotation now they're down to the 0.3
degree level they've come a long way I
also pointed out after the discovery of
the accelerating universe that dark
energy could do this certain candidates
for Dark Energy axion-like Dark Energy
candidates could lead to this Cosmic
birefringence so my personal happiness
would be maximized if this is true since
I was there on the ground floor predict
lifting this cosmological birefringence
but it's very very difficult to detect
and it's it's easy to you know have a
small effect go away so I'm still going
to wait until we have more data before I
get very excited about this the other
thing in addition to the fact that it's
still there is I believe and this is
something again not completely an expert
on because I haven't been following it
carefully enough but my impression is
well you have to worry about foregrounds
right when you're looking at
polarization in the cosmic migrate
background it's in a very very tiny
numbers that you're looking at and our
galaxy is full of dust that can lead to
polarization that can confuse you Etc
and my impression is that what you do is
you try to you know you do your best to
take into account the fact that the
Galaxy is there and the galaxy has dust
in it Etc and remove that from the data
but to be sure to check that you've done
it correctly what you can do is just
literally cut out the Galaxy so what you
typically do is to try to
compensate for the fact that the Galaxy
is there but keep the data in the
direction of the actual Galaxy we live
in but then you compare to what would
happen if you just ignored all of the
data in the direction of the Galaxy in
the galactic plane around us okay in the
circle of the galactic equator if you
want to put it that way and there you
have less data right because now you're
only looking up away from the Galaxy or
down away from the plane of a galaxy but
you're at least you're not being
contaminated by the Galaxy itself and my
impression is that when you do that the
effect becomes less strong from the
analysis that has been done so on the
one hand maybe that's just because you
have less data on the other hand maybe
it's because the effect was originally
from contamination from the Galaxy
that's why this is hard that's why it's
way easier to be a theorist than an
observer an experimentalist in this game
so trust me if there's actually any
progress to the point where I think that
this is
probably right you will hear about it
from me I'm not going to keep that one
from you
brandonk says You seem to have spent a
lot of time and energy focusing on
natural Philosophy for a while now
thinking not just about the empirical
science of physics but the philosophical
underpinnings and implications of
physics and Science in general this is
no small task as physics and philosophy
of science are each deep rich and
difficult to master in their own
independent respects have you
encountered any major challenges to your
ways of thinking as you've engaged with
more of the underlying philosophy or any
kind of shift in perspective
so one thing to say is I don't think
it's that different honestly what I'm
doing now uh than what I did before it's
true that my research shift research
Focus has shifted a bit but it is still
very much the same driving question
trying to understand the nature of our
physical world okay trying to use uh
some combination of empirical input and
rational thought to come up with the
best possible models of reality the
difference in the sort of thinking of it
in a more philosophical way is just that
which questions you tackle and the
methods you use to tackle them are a
little bit different but the same
underlying goal is there so if you care
about Quantum Mechanics for example
um on the foundational or philosophical
side of things you're going to worry a
lot about the fundamental ontology of
quantum mechanics whether the wave
function is real things like that what
happens when you make a measurement or
it collapses if you're just a typical
run-of-the-mill physicist you just plug
into the formulas and get on with your
life you don't worry about those things
but still either person is interested in
understanding the fundamental laws of
physics okay so the question
um have I encountered any major
challenges Etc I wouldn't say that no I
I would say that rather
as exactly should happen if you're doing
philosophy or foundational work well you
come across places where there were
things that you thought were pretty well
established and pretty well figured out
and suddenly you go oh wait a minute
that might not be right at all and I
think you know to me like the obvious
example is the anthropic principle and I
talked about this over the summer in a
Solo episode on the philosophy of
cosmology I think we do the anthropic
principle very very badly in cosmology I
think it's a potentially important thing
to get right and I think that physicists
are very sloppy about it you know the
typical physicist way of thinking is
there's many wrong ways to get the right
answer but that's okay because if we get
the wrong answer nature will tell us
we'll do an experiment and we'll find
out but for some of these questions like
the Multiverse and the anthropic
principle Nature's not going to tell you
whether you've done it wrong or not
because you're talking about things you
can't observe that makes it more
important than ever to make sure your
reasoning is valid okay and so I think
this is exactly a case where a more
philosophical approach is useful and
it's certainly changed my views of some
claims in uh cosmology nothing major
that would really overthrow anything but
you know things that might end up being
important
Michael monhalt says what kind of
qualitative influence does gravity have
on LHC experiments at CERN I'm referring
both to the Earth's gravity and to the
tiny gravity of most particles involved
well the tiny gravity of most particles
involved at the Large Hadron Collider is
completely completely completely
negligible no effect whatsoever that's
there's one foot note there which is
that people speculated that maybe
gravity is much stronger than you think
at these high energies and short
distances and so that was a an idea that
led to large extra dimensions and
searching for gravitons at the large
adron collider but it didn't work they
didn't find anything yet again as with
any such statement maybe they will find
something tomorrow but as of right now
as of this recording they haven't found
anything so as far as we know the
gravity the gravitational interactions
of particles of the Large Hadron
Collider are completely completely
negligible now for the Earth that's a
different thing obviously the LHC is you
know kilometers across I used to know
the number of kilometers 17 kilometers
in circumference maybe
um but that no 17 miles 30 kilometers
maybe I forgot but it's been a while
since I wrote a book but I did write a
book that has all these numbers on it
the particle at the End of the Universe
um
a machine that large sits in the
gravitational field of the earth and
that matters when you're trying to do
Precision experiments so in fact
um I believe you know I'm not an expert
because I'm not a an experimentalist at
CERN but I remember reading that you
could detect the moon using Large Hadron
Collider because the tides the tidal
gravitational force of the Moon led to
very tiny shifts in the instruments that
were experimentally detectable happily
we already know the Moon is there so
this was not a mystery it was known to
be something that you would take into
account so yes the gravity of the Earth
and the moon do matter for those
experiments a tiny tiny amount but
they're noticeable the gravity of
individual particles don't matter at all
Funk says in chapter 8 of the biggest
ideas of the universe in the universe on
general relativity you suggest that all
kinds of energy including things like
pressure and stress contribute to the
curvature of space-time after recently
wrapping my head around the fact that
planets in orbit have negative potential
energy as do electrons and atoms I found
myself wondering if this negative
potential energy does then also
contribute a negative amount due the
curvature of space-time and thus
effectively acts like the presence of
some negative Mass
good so there's two things going on here
um one thing is when you say when we say
because I say it too that planets in
orbit have negative potential energy
you know compared to what
potential energy is an example of
something where the only physical effect
in good old classical Newtonian
mechanics is differences in potential
energy what the right thing to say is
that two gravitating objects that are
far away from each other have more
energy than if you bring them close by
so that their CL their gravitational
force is stronger okay and you know that
that's true because you know that it
would take energy to move them away
again so you need to put energy into the
system to take two particles that are
orb two planets that are orbiting each
other and separate them therefore there
is a negative amount of potential energy
there compared to the energy when
they're not right next to each other but
the absolute value of that energy is
just not even defined in Newtonian
mechanics in general relativity it's a
little bit different because the total
amount of energy does matter the the
absolute zero point matters not just the
relative amount of energy but there's
another subtle LTE and I apologize if
this was not clear enough in the book
but the right hand side of Einstein's
equation the side that acts that tells
you the source for Gravity what is
called the energy momentum tensor which
includes mass and momentum and heat and
energy whatever it is all sorts of
energy densities and pressures and all
those things
is really very very strictly only the
energy in stuff
not the energy in gravity or the
curvature of space-time itself the
curvature of space-time is entirely on
the left hand side of Einstein's
equation so Einstein's equation is
strictly saying that the curvature of
space-time is sourced by the energy not
in space time but in everything else in
all the matter and radiation and stuff
in the universe
having said that the left hand side does
have the curvature of space-time in it
and it implies that the curvature of
space-time affects itself it is
non-linear okay A little bit of
curvature of space-time can push around
the curvature of space-time but it's not
as simple as negative potential energy
or anything like that it's a complicated
non-linear thing at the end of the day
what is the most relevant
statement I can make for a question like
this is
empty space is stable in general
relativity in general relativity there's
what is called a positive energy theorem
under again under reasonable
circumstances you can't get Negative
masses just by curving space-time in
weird ways so when I say that empty
space is stable what I mean is that if
there's nothing in the universe but
empty space it can't Decay into a
positive energy part and a negative
energy part right anything you do
anytime you poke empty space to make it
Ripple or gravitational waves or
whatever you're increasing the total
energy you're never decreasing it so
when you're at that minimum of energy
empty space perfectly flat there's
nowhere to go down and therefore
everything is perfectly stable
Jim Watson says for Gravity waves is it
a wave in the sense of a harmonic
oscillator whereby there is some
restorative force in the space-time
Fabric and abrupt perturbances of
curvature cause transitory under damped
fluctuations with more or less curvature
or is it more like an over damped or
critically damped oscillator and the
wave isn't from restorative energy in
the fabric itself but rather the orbital
motion of the mass making periodic
changes to the curvature each orbit
well let me say by way of background
that you have to be careful when kind of
appealing to these analogies okay like
oscillators and
um masses making periodic changes at the
end of the day these are all words that
we're attaching to the equations
uh in particular when you think about
oscillating things in your experience
you will be tempted by the fact that
real oscillating things eventually
dissipate their energy right they stop
oscillating so you talk about damped
oscillations right there in the question
but
there's nothing if there's a
gravitational wave in space time much
like if there is a light wave in space
time if there's an electromagnetic wave
and there's nothing else there in the
universe for it to bump into there's no
dissipation there's no running out of of
energy right the energy is conserved in
that thing so that gravitational wave
will continue on forever
and but I think to answer the actual
thrust of your question it is a wave in
the sense of a harmonic oscillator in
the sense that it is different nearby
regions of space-time that are pulling
on each other and pushing back and
causing that oscillation in exactly the
same way that it's nearby regions of an
electromagnetic wave that push and pull
on each other so it's it's a very very
good analogy there it's just that energy
is conserved so the the oscillations
never go away they just move from place
to place
Rue Phillips says what is your
perspective on Christian nationalism and
its impact on U.S politics is it to be
respected as an expression of American
ideals a credible threat to democracy or
something else
well you know I never know quite what to
think about these things because the
labeling game is very tricky when you
talk about Christian nationalism is this
a self-given label to some group of
people are there are there people who
are describing themselves as Christian
nationalists or are people who disagree
with them describing themselves as
Christian nationalists and I bet that
it's both uh sometimes but I don't
actually know the relative frequency of
those things
you know there is an ongoing debate in
the United States about whether or not
certain movements can be characterized
as fascist for example or white
nationalist and
maybe maybe not I think that you know
there's similarities differences
whatever you can have a debate about
that but it hard to use words like
Nazism or fascism or something like that
without giving the game away in terms of
evaluating right those are so highly
charged terms and maybe they deserve to
be that that's fine but when you call
someone a fascist you're not sort of
entering into dialogue with them right
there's not a lot of people who are
self-proclaimed happy fascists out there
today at least not in the United States
so I actually have but there is
something going on that is resembling
that kind of fascism so what is a more
value-neutral term that you could invent
I think maybe
uh this isn't exactly very good but the
closest I can come up with right now is
romantic nationalism the idea of sort of
putting your nation ahead of not only
other nations but also the individual
citizens inside your nation the the
iconography of
you know the the over-the-top sort of
kitschy portrayals of patriotism and
might military might and things like
that
um might be accurately labeled romantic
nationalism whether or not you want to
be for it or against it right
um Christian nationalism of course is
part of the actual way the Romantic
nationalism manifests itself in the
United States as is white nationalism
but in very complicated ways because
there are people within these movements
who are not Christian who are not white
Etc
I don't think any of these ways of
thinking about politics are expressions
of American ideals in any real sense I
think that the ideals to the extent that
even makes sense to talk about American
ideals I think that those ideals should
include a certain Cosmopolitan openness
to different people different cultures
Etc I think that's an important part of
what makes America America when it is
doing good things sometimes America does
bad things and then its ideals are not
so great
um is it a credible threat to democracy
yeah absolutely I mean we literally had
an Insurrection take over the United
States capital cheered on by the
president of the United States like
that's pretty credible as a threat to
democracy goes we had a very very
coordinated effort to overthrow the
result of an election we have an ongoing
campaign to put people in positions of
power so that next time they can do a
better job of it I think these are super
credible threats to democracy and I
would like to take them very seriously
because I think that democracy is good
all things being equal
Igor velotic says I've recently stumbled
across some conversations including Noam
Chomsky in which he said that science
currently recognizes only two concepts
determinacy and Randomness and does not
go beyond that the context was regarding
human ability to grasp the world around
and about our current limits
could you even grasp the possibility
that there is anything that goes beyond
determinacy and Randomness or is this
something you wouldn't generally waste
your time contemplating
so I answered this question a little
tentatively because I didn't stumble
across that conversation with Chomsky so
I can't verify that that's actually what
he said that current science only
recognizes two concepts I mean currently
you know clearly that can't be exactly
right scientific current science
recognizes plenty of Concepts
um so what must have been meant is that
there is some distinction drawn between
determinacy and Randomness and that
distinction is purportedly comprehensive
that processes are either determinant or
deterministic or random
I I maybe I'm missing something but it
sounds to me like those are the two
options because the definition of random
is not determinant I think I'm not sure
the definition of random is that's
that's the trickiness that's where some
possible
scope for Thought uh lays here because
what do you mean by random do you just
mean that you personally were unable to
predict it do you mean that it does not
depend uh in any
um completely solid way on what happened
before in the universe or are you doing
something a little bit more
sophisticated about
epistemic subjective approaches to
probability in our knowledge I don't
know so I'm not exactly sure what is
meant by Randomness there not to mention
of course the fact that quantum
mechanics is a classic example of
something where we use Randomness in our
applications of it but we don't agree on
what that Randomness is it depends on
your formulation of the foundations of
quantum mechanics but I don't but I I
don't know what would be an example of
something that was neither determinism
nor Randomness so I that's not a very
good answer there but that's the best I
can do for that question
Humberto Nani says I read the following
your book The Big Picture the maximum
entropy region of space can contain is
higher when the vacuum energy is lower
can you please explain why it is so
well it's basically because the
observable universe can be bigger when
the vacuum energy is lower the vacuum
energy we're limiting ourselves here to
vacuum energies that are not negative
negative is a whole different thing than
you get into anti-decider space since
it's a different story so the positive
vacuum energy story is desitter space
desitter spaces the solution to
Einstein's equations of general
relativity that you get when there's
nothing in the universe but positive
vacuum energy and the higher the vacuum
energy is the more the universe is the
more the space time is curved right the
faster the universe is accelerating and
therefore the smaller the Horizon is the
sitter space or an accelerating universe
is characterized by a horizon that is to
say if you're at any one point in
space-time there's a region inside of
which you can see things uh light can
travel to you and outside that region
light can never reach you because the
universe is expanding to vast so
the higher the vacuum energy the faster
the universe is expanding the smaller
the region is inside your Horizon and
therefore the less entropy it's going to
have the formula for the entropy is the
same as the formula for the entropy of a
black hole it goes to the area of that
Horizon around you and that Horizon is
smaller when the vacuum energy is larger
Tom B Knight says I write science
fiction and mindscape is a constant
source of inspiration I'm working on a
new novel and wanted to want to know
what are the implications of recent
advances in nuclear fusion for creating
a pure fusion bomb I.E one that doesn't
require efficient reaction to trigger
the larger fusion reaction
so I'm not an expert on recent the
recent advances in nuclear fusion there
have been a couple of questions in the
amas about them that I have not answered
for just that reason I'm not an expert I
have nothing really enlightening to say
about it
um
but I'm pretty confident in saying that
there are almost no implications for
creating a pure fusion bomb the point is
that even to do there have been the
examples recently where Fusion has
happened they've made Fusion happen Okay
and the question is you know how
difficult is it to get it to happen
right now it's still at the state where
you need to put more energy in than
you're getting out net at the end of the
day so you're not making overall energy
from doing Fusion but you're creating a
little bit of fusion but still doing
that requires a Jai humongous machine
right an enormous kind of setup with
lasers or plasmas trapped or magnetic
fields or whatever it requires to make
just a little tiny pellet of hydrogen
undergo nuclear fusion
so this is just not what you want for a
bomb at all okay I mean certainly for a
bomb you want something where you get
much more energy out than you put in you
don't want the battery in your bomb to
be putting more energy in than you get
out of the explosion otherwise it's not
a very efficient bomb and also you want
it to be small you want to be able to
carry it on a plane so I don't even
think that people are contemplating
using techniques from controlled nuclear
fusion to make different kinds of bombs
could be wrong about that not my area of
expertise but that is my physicist on
the street impression there
Anonymous says in episode 219 with Perry
zern and Danny Bassett you discuss the
idea of spotlighting gaps in your
knowledge base to stimulate curiosity
and discovery
asking the right question creates a
vacuum the curious minds can't help but
try to fill are there any known
lesser-known historical examples that
you could share from physics or
elsewhere
I don't have any examples off the top of
my head I mean I kind of wanted to
answer this question but didn't have any
good answers for it
um you know but it's absolutely true
asking the right question creates a
vacuum the curious minds can't help but
try to fill the one kind of close
example that came to mind is the Fermi
Paradox right Enrico Fermi sitting down
at lunch at the University of Chicago
and saying like why aren't there aliens
everywhere
the time scale with which an alien
civilization could fill our galaxy with
evidence of their existence is much
smaller noticeably smaller anyway than
the age of the universe or the age of
the oldest stars or Star systems so if
technological civilizations were easy
were ubiquitous in the universe they
could have left Trails very very
long ago and very very obviously and yet
we don't see them so
this was a simple question right I mean
it's sort of an example of just thinking
about something and realizing there's a
puzzle that you hadn't appreciated
before and from that people put a lot of
effort into thinking about it is really
helped focus our discussions such as
they are about life elsewhere in the
universe and you know maybe that's not a
tangible result that has come out of it
yet but you can't have a discussion
about Advanced alien life without
talking about the Fermi Paradox which is
a pretty good consequence for a
lunchtime table discussion anywhere
Matt Grinder says the experiment where
you send a single Photon 3 beam splitter
and half the waves go to one detector
half go to another detector seems to
show that Quantum waves cannot carry
energy since you get a full photons
worth of energy at one detector not half
a photon hence Quantum waves must be
only probability sorry hence Quantum
waves must be only probability waves and
there's more to the question after that
but all the subsequent question relies
on that little argument that comes at
the start so I wanted to point out this
argument is not right it is not true
that you only get
um because you get a full photons worth
of energy Quantum waves must only be
probability waves and you know that
can't be true because we have counter
examples namely the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
where the quantum wave is not just a
probability wave and yet you see the
full photons worth of energy at one
detector not half a photon's worth of
energy why is that well the answer is
you had one branch of the wave function
of the universe with a certain amount of
energy and it branched in half and the
whole universe
that it branches into the two universes
it branches into have half the energy
each roughly speaking maybe not exactly
but pretty close to half the energy each
and you don't notice that because you
yourself are part of that diluting that
thinning out in the wave function of the
universe I've talked about this many
times and never necessarily very
successfully but the universe sort of
gets skinnier in a very real sense so it
is true that you detected one Photon not
half a photon but that's exactly what
you would predict on the basis of saying
the quantum waves are not just
probability waves but are actually the
physical universe
Andrew Goldstein says I'm reading Karen
Baker's recent book the sounds of Life
how digital Technologies bringing us
closer to the worlds of animals and
plants given your pursuit of physics and
natural philosophy and having read the
big picture where you discussed some
length Consciousness and sentience I'm
curious how you think the growing
knowledge of animal and even plant
communication might affect our
understanding and definition of
consciousness
so I don't know uh probably not that
much is my guess I think it will affect
our understanding of animal and plant
communication and animal implant
cognition to the extent that there is
cognition you know I think this is a
it's a tricky thing and I actually don't
have super strong feelings about this
but here are the feelings that I do have
that two things are simultaneously true
one is that
human beings are part of life on Earth
We're Not Like A distinct thing we are
animals ourselves so animal
communication includes human
communication there is a sense uh there
are differences in degree but not in
kind we have common ancestors with all
the animals and the plants that's one
thing that is true another thing that is
true is that we are clearly different
from other animals and plants we're the
only species that has podcasts is a
silly way of putting it but you gotta be
pretty determined not to look around you
to not notice that there are some
differences between human life here on
Earth and the life of other animals and
plants here on Earth in part because of
the ways that we think in the ways we
communicate and the we the ways that we
manipulate our natural environment it
doesn't mean that the differences are
discontinuous that somehow something
magical happened that once and for all
differentiated human beings from
everything else but it does mean that
certain capacities that human beings uh
got over the course of evolutionary time
gave us abilities that other animals
don't have that doesn't mean that we're
special in any way you know it doesn't
mean that we're deserving of uh domain
or dominion over the Earth or it doesn't
have any normative implications right
away you can make normative arguments on
the basis of it but as a descriptive
statement there are differences between
humans and other species and humans and
other species share a common existence
here on Earth common ancestry made out
of the same stuff very closely related
in some in some cases so
I don't think that any
discoveries about animal and plant
communication will suddenly affect our
definition of Consciousness I don't know
what our definition of Consciousness is
I think that Consciousness is kind of a
vague term and one of the things that we
learn by doing neuroscience and
psychology is not what is the right
definition of Consciousness but what are
the different aspects of human thought
and being that go into making up what we
call Consciousness and I think it's very
very interesting and important and we've
talked on the podcast about how other
animals communicate with each other and
how they think and how they reason and
how it's similar and different
um but I think that we should give the
animals Credit in the sense that when we
study them we're studying them we're not
trying to learn more about us
Sandro stooki says I recently
re-listened to mindscape episode with
David Wallace and notice you promised to
record an extra discussion with him as a
bonus for patreons did that ever happen
I like that episode a lot so I'd love to
hear the bonus so no it did not happen
and I think it's an exaggeration to say
that I promised anything I speculated
about a possibility of doing that
um and I don't know so the reason why I
am answering the question is because you
know I have wondered whether or not it
would be worth the effort and the answer
as soon as you say is it worth the
effort is usually no but effort is
something in short supply right now
um are there better ways to do the model
of the podcast you know the current
model is there's a free version that
everyone gets that has ads there is a
version that far far fewer people get
with no ads for the patreon supporters
um wondery is is uh the place where you
can get the uh version with ads but it
gets you know sent everywhere whereas
you have to go to patreon and be a
supporter to get the ad free version and
so the bone the the reason why what are
the reasons why anyone would contribute
to the patreon well one is just like a
sense of belonging right or giving
appreciation uh to the creator of
whatever it is you're supporting on
patreon another is that there are some
benefits in the case of mindscape the
benefits are the ability to ask these
AMA questions and of course the the
ad-free versions
is there any model where uh I could not
have any version with ads like have all
the versions be ad-free but nevertheless
uh get the same income that I get from
doing it because I like income and it
keeps me motivated to keep doing the
podcast I would probably keep doing the
podcast anyway but I can't be sure
because attention is short and I might
downshift quite a bit if the income were
quite a bit lower
so is there you know if we didn't have
ads in the regular version I'm presuming
that there would be fewer patreon
supporters right because some people who
support on patreon probably do because
they don't want the ads the number of
people who ask AMA questions is also
noticeably smaller than the number of
people who uh support on patreon so
asking AMA questions can't be the only
reason
I think that some people don't care
about the ads and would be happy to
support even if there were ads but some
others don't is there something else
that I could do that would let people
that even if no version had ads would
still count as a bonus for people who
are supporting on patreon or elsewhere
maybe there's another way better way to
do it with sub stack or something like
that I don't know so that's what your
question sparked in me thinking about
extra bonus stuff whether it's extra
interviews or X like so one thing to do
is maybe there's an hour or hour 15
minute regular podcast that everyone
gets and there's an extra 10 or 15
minute more informal chit chat with the
podcast guest or you know a personal
thing that is just me talking and only
patreon supporters get to listen to that
I don't love that idea right off the bat
because it seems to require more work
for me but you know maybe it's it's
something that people would prefer I
don't know so I'm offering this
opportunity if you're out there
listening to chime in in the comments or
whatever to let me know you know if
there is a possible way that you think
you know we could run things that
wouldn't be a lot of extra work that
would be more valuable to you that you
would actually appreciate it more I mean
I it it doesn't make any difference when
you do the podcast even if the income
were the same if nobody were listening I
would not be doing the podcast I I do
want to have an impact uh and and give
something to the people who are actually
the listeners to the show
Douglas long says when I was much
younger I remember reading a book that
discussed the two types of people in the
world competitive and Cooperative in a
nutshell being the latter and being in a
position to tangle with the former I
added this to the back of my business
card there are two types of people in
the world competitive and Cooperative
competitive people push Cooperative
people until they become competitive
therefore competitive people think all
people are competitive
you know roughly speaking I think that
anything that starts with two types of
people in the world is going to be not
exactly true an exaggeration uh but you
know maybe a useful lens right so the
question is is it useful to group people
even if approximately and informally
into these groups of competitive versus
Cooperative
um I don't know I don't know if that's
actually true I think that the number of
Dimensions along which it's important to
measure people's
Essence is higher dimensional than just
that one so the competitive versus
Cooperative axis so I don't know I I
have nothing uh special to say about
this other than it's I would worry that
something like that is a bit simplistic
and it's the kind of simple rule that
can seem very tempting but you should
watch out for taking it too seriously or
pushing it too far
Sean Coram says I've read in a few
different popular science articles I
read yeah in a few different popular
science articles that say that while
dark matter doesn't Clump in the modern
cosmological era back in the era of
proto-galaxies Dark Matter was much more
clumped up and mixed in with ordinary
matter what's going on with that so
that's just false just not true the
density clumpiness of dark matter is
certainly higher now than it was uh much
longer ago back in the cosmic microwave
background days the clumpiness was
almost negligible one part in a hundred
thousand and now it is very noticeable
it's very easy to see that there's more
dark matter in galaxies and clusters
than in between them so I don't know
what popular science article was telling
you that but it's just not true
Joshua hillerup says from my
understanding there are ways to use
general relativity as an effective field
Theory within the standard model or with
the standard model and we haven't done
any experiments that contradict what
that would predict does that approach
also make consistent predictions of what
would happen with observing a tiny black
hole evaporating into nothing
so no it doesn't make uh predictions
about that really the the you can
absolutely include general relativity as
an effective field Theory along with the
standard model we call it the core
Theory you can even buy a t-shirt from
me that has the core Theory printed on
it but there are limitations there is a
domain of applicability of that theory
and black holes are not in that domain
it only makes sense to use General
relativity's effective field theory in
regions where gravity is pretty weak and
by construction a black hole is not a
region where gravity is weak now again
as usual there's complications Etc there
are ways to use techniques from
effective field Theory to do
calculations with black holes in
particular calculations about the
gravitational radiation from black holes
but black hole evaporation it would be I
don't know of a way to consistently do
that in the realm of effective field
Theory or let's put it this way you
would be missing the presumably
important part of black hole evaporation
how the information gets out of black
holes that's certainly that's kind of
the whole reason why we call it a black
hole information loss puzzle because if
you just do Quantum field Theory you're
not getting the information out from the
black hole so you have to go beyond that
so effective field theory is not up to
the task
Robert ruxandrescue says suppose the
Higgs field would turn off go to zero
value all the quarks that comprise
protons and neutrons would then have
zero Mass considering that zero Mass
particles travel at the speed of light
with all the protons and neutrons
explode
so the throat answer is no
um there's a calculation you have to do
you have to ask quantitatively can you
would you be able to have a bound state
of three quarks plus gluons that you
would recognize as a proton or a neutron
even if the quarks were massless most of
the energy in a Proton or Neutron does
not come from the Quark masses the Quark
masses are a tiny part of the total mass
of those nucleons so roughly speaking it
wouldn't matter that much you wouldn't
change a lot by setting those masses to
zero but there is a calculation you have
to do to make sure that's right and I
haven't done the calculation so you
should check me if you're skeptical
about that
um but it's a couple of clarifying
statements that maybe might help make
sense of this for one thing they're not
particles right they're Fields really
inside a proton or a neutron is a
paradigmatic place where you can't
ignore Quantum field Theory where you
really have to think about the fact that
there are fields and there's quantum
mechanics it's not just little like
particles zooming around so to say zero
Mass particles move at the speed of
light is actually not giving you that
much insight into what happens inside a
Proton or Neutron keep in mind there are
gluons inside the protons and neutrons
and they are massless they do move at
the speed of light in the they would be
moving the speed of light were they to
be free particles but they're not free
particles they're confined inside these
strongly interacting particles so the
right thing to do in the strong
interactions in qcd is just solve the
equations for low energy configurations
of these particular Quantum Fields okay
and you get an answer and it's supposed
to look like a baryon like a proton or a
neutron uh one one way of thinking about
it which I only say you know with some
trepidation because it's a different
metaphor that may or may not be helpful
is these particles are strongly
interacting so they're constantly
bumping into each other and interacting
with each other so even if something
moves at the speed of light if it's
stuck between two mirrors it'll just
back bounce back and forth between those
two mirrors right it doesn't mean it
goes far away or explodes it can still
be confined to a small region And yet
when it's moving it's moving at the
speed of light think of the gluon tons
and the quarks if they were massless
inside protons and neutrons like that
they're moving at the speed of light but
not in a straight line they're moving
around inside again it's not even
actually true they're not moving at all
but I think that's a pretty good
colorful
analogy or metaphor to think about
paulheim says when Malaysian Airlines
370 went missing what accompanied my
sadness was a sense of hope and mystery
that is still possible for something as
large and well monitored as an airliner
to be lost on Earth as a devotee of the
age of polar exploration I've always
wondered if something was lost from the
human Spirit once the polls were visited
the Space Race kicked off a world in
which the remaining Frontiers are
predominantly perhaps almost entirely of
the technological variety that's not to
say these Feats are any less impressive
or momentous or to say that earlier
explorers didn't exploit the technology
of their day but they strike me as
fundamentally different do you have any
thoughts on what might have been lost as
a result of this transition
you know I don't I don't feel that loss
myself I I get it I'm not uh going to
undermine your personal sense of loss I
think that's perfectly legitimate thing
to think but it's a kind of nostalgia at
the end of the day
um it's a game that is being played you
know well going to the poll or going
circumnavigating the Earth is much
harder if you have primitive technology
than if you have advanced technology
people circumnavigate the globe all the
time these days right
um I I'm happy that we've explored the
globe it's it's kind of like playing a
video game right where you explore the
world and there are certain parts you've
already explored and you don't want to
do that part anymore you want to go on
to a new part
there's plenty of Frontiers
there that we have not yet explored not
only in outer space but the bottom of
the ocean right very largely unexplored
lots of Antarctica and so forth but you
know personally if I'm talking about my
own views
um the explorations I care about are
mostly intellectual Explorations
learning things there's many things that
we don't know and doing science and
learning new things is a very real kind
of exploration there were nowhere close
to running out of things to explore so I
don't think that the spirit of human
exploration is has in any sense been
lost
Anonymous says there are many animals
that follow sensible survival strategies
because they do certain behaviors by
Instinct not because they're thinking
things through and making plans
squirrels burying nuts Etc I see
parallels to human behavior and ideas
about religion and spirituality in all
this unconscious high performance in
nature we are a social species in a
storytelling meaning making species I
can imagine it can be beneficial to our
survival to tell stories about why it
feels right and gets good results and we
follow our instincts to cooperate
I've seen plenty of attempts to pit
science and spirituality against each
other but I've never seen a scientist
imply that a bird is doing anything
wrong or misguided when it migrates even
though the bird is probably not acting
logically and even though the bird may
very well be having an internal
experience that is similar to the
internal experience a human has when
following a faith practice what do you
think of the idea that human religious
or spiritual impulses can fit within
science in the same category as a bird's
impulse to migrate as a natural
instinctive behavior that some but not
all people find compelling
you know I think I think that two things
are being mixed up here a little bit
there's a descriptive and a prescriptive
element
people can study why other people or
themselves are religious what purposes
are served by being religious what is
the evolutionary basis for being
religious what are the benefits socially
and individually of religious experience
those are all things that are absolutely
worth studying just as you can study why
birds migrate right in exactly the same
way and that's a perfectly sensible
thing to do there's no conflict between
science and religion there the conflict
comes when you say okay I have a goal
I have a an ambition to do the following
thing namely to correctly understand the
universe right maybe you don't have that
goal that's okay
but if you do then science and religion
generally speaking I know because you
always Define religion in weird ways but
generally speaking they offer two
incompatible answers to the question of
what the universe is and how it behaves
at a fundamental level and both answers
can't be right so if you have that goal
of best understanding how the world
Works science and religion are going to
conflict like turning left and turning
right at a stop sign conflict you can't
do both right and of course that's not
the only way they can conflict there's
also questions of whether or not
religion has bad implications not just
good implications but whether it gets in
the way of being a moral person or
things like that but putting all those
aside just at the level of Science and
religion they're offering incompatible
answers to deep questions and that's
where to me the important conflict comes
from and by the way they didn't have to
right it could have been in some other
possible world that the answers to how
the universe is that were offered by
religion were studied scientifically and
turned out to be right that could have
been the world it just isn't the actual
World in which we live
Jared duriegas says as a lifelong San
Antonio Spurs fan I was spoiled by many
good years in the past but now find my
team actively trying to underperform and
tank for a better chance to draft a
generational talent I was curious your
feelings on tanking in sports and in
general the morality of gaming systems
and choosing shortcuts I can't help but
feel this question pertains to Everyday
Life as well do we owe it to others
sometimes to choose a harder path
against our own self-interest
so I think that if you're literally a
sports franchise
that is an example where it makes sense
to play by whatever rules are set up
like that's what you do in sports right
and maybe in other wider circumstances
playing by the rules that have been set
up is not the thing to do maybe you
should rebel against the rules Etc but
if you're literally a sports franchise
you play by the rules that's what that's
what you do and I don't think that it's
gaming the system to play by the rules
to benefit the chances that your team
wins a championship that's that's again
what you're supposed to do if you don't
like that if you don't like that
behavior change the rules
I do think that it you know so for those
of you who are not sports fans out there
um in basketball in particular although
in all sports to some extent
it's really important to have the best
players right of course it's good to
have the best players overall but
because in a basketball team you only
have five people on the court at any one
time there's an outsized influence to
the best player on the team unlike you
know football team has 11 players out
there and they have completely separate
teams for offense and defense so there's
lots of people who have an impact
um American football that is basketball
you don't fight people out there there's
some bench players Etc but basically
five people so one person really matters
basically there's 30 teams in the NBA
and if you do not have one of the 10
best players in the league it is almost
impossible to win the championship
if you go back in uh I did this I was
inspired by this question to actually
you know just check my Recollections and
indeed uh the last team to win the NBA
championship without one of the League's
best 10 players it was arguably the
Detroit Pistons in 2004 and before that
it was the Detroit Pistons again in the
1990s with a completely different team
so I don't know what it is with the
water in Detroit that allows this
wonderful sort of Team Basketball to be
played but other than the Pistons if you
want to win the championship going back
to the 1970s you had to have one of the
best players in the league and therefore
how do you get one of the best players
in the league sometimes you can be lucky
and be a glamor franchise like the LA
Lakers and just wait for the players to
come to you like LeBron James did but if
you're not one of those glamor
franchises you have to draft them
um when they first enter the league and
so there's an enormous premium on
getting good draft choices and who gets
the best draft choices the worst teams
there's this idea that you should
help everyone get a chance by giving the
best draft choices to the worst teams
but that incentivizes being the worst
team obviously you'd rather be the best
team but if you don't have one of those
10 best players you're not going to be
the best team and therefore your
incentive is to try to be the worst team
so you maximize your chances of getting
the best player right the next best
player
and I absolutely feel the
the sensibleness of the critique that
says that's terrible you're
incentivizing losing games and everyone
should be trying their best to win the
games by the way the players and the
coaches almost entirely try to win the
games when a team is tanking when a team
is trying to as a franchise be the worst
that's generally the front office that
just trades away all their good players
so the players that they are remaining
with and the coaches are doing their
best you know they're they're giving out
they're all out there but they're just
not very good and that's a good way to
get a great player the Philadelphia
76ers my favorite team did that and we
have Joel embiid a top two player in the
NBA right now and so we are at least
have a chance of competing for the NBA
title it works
but how do you get around that I think
of the right way to get around that if
it really bothers you
don't give the worst teams the best
draft choices that's the only thing you
can do and you know people try to tweak
the percentages the NBA is constantly
changing the percentage chance of
getting the best pick right what is
called the NBA lottery but the total
probability of getting someone getting
the best pick remains constant so all
they do when they change the
probabilities are move the incentives
from one set of teams to another one
they don't get rid of the incentives in
any realistic way
if you say the worst team gets the the
uh best pick then you're highly
incentivized to be the worst team if you
say the worst 10 teams have an equal
chance then okay you have no incentive
to be the worst team we have a really
strong incentive to be one of the bottom
10 teams so it can't go away there has
been suggestions for equalizing the
draft Equity there's something called
The Wheel which was a proposal by Mike
Zarin who is a I think a Celtics
executive which basically says every
team gets a predetermined draft choice
each year each franchise picks in a in a
certain sequence and every year the
sequence changes so that every 30 years
you cycle through all the different
possibilities right and so there
therefore you can't benefit from being
bad in any way there's essentially zero
motivation or you know momentum for
doing a plan like that uh for various
reasons I don't think the reasons are
very good but I don't think there's
anything wrong in sports or elsewhere by
playing by the rules and elsewhere
outside Sports where the rules are
things that we make up or you know
someone else made up and we don't agree
with there could be more incentive to
try to change the rules but whatever the
rules are playing within them in a
sports context makes sense to me
Liam emptin says apart from their
epistemological role science and
philosophy have a psychological impact
in our lives reinforcing our sense of
optimism and wonderment do you ever see
science this way in your daily life EG
do you listen to science podcasts
outside of your field of expertise after
a long stressful day
I mean I absolutely see those roles
science and philosophy having uh
reinforcing our sense of optimism and
wonderment I get that but it does not
lead to me listening to science podcasts
outside my field of expertise after a
long stressful day after a long
stressful day my long stressful days are
largely dominated by science and
philosophy so I do not de-stress by
listening to science and philosophy
podcasts I would much rather read Pride
and Prejudice for a fifth time or
something like that or watch the Sixers
lose another nail biter game
um yeah I think that the best way to
unwind after a long stressful day is to
shift gears mentally and do something
very different from whatever you do
during your everyday life so I I do very
strongly think that I would not be happy
if I focused my intellectual efforts in
a very narrow regime of Science and
philosophy that's why I have a podcast
that's literally why that was my
incentive for starting this more than
anything else was when I was writing the
big picture I got to talk to a whole
bunch of people in different fields and
that was fun and so the podcast is a way
for me to be able to talk to a whole
bunch of experts in different fields but
between doing my work and making the
podcast and writing and things like that
I do not have much energy left over for
listening to other science podcasts and
that's not to say they're not great and
you should not listen to them and we
should all reinforce our sense of
optimism and wonderment all that sounds
great to me
nalita s says what is the most
mind-blowing physics discovery that you
live through in your opinion what about
the one before you were born
well I think yeah it depends what you
mean that I lived through I know that
shouldn't be that ambiguous but of
course I'm going to count lived through
as I was a grown-up and paying attention
to scientific discoveries right not
since I was literally a baby and in that
case if that's the definition then it's
absolutely clear that the answer is the
accelerating universe the dark energy
the cosmological constant in 1998.
um which was very surprising and
crucially important it's a little bit
frustrating because it's just one number
like we measured it and we measured the
number and so what are you going to do
with it you can be inspired to try to
think of an explanation for it and I
have and people have Etc but we haven't
settled on with the right explanation is
and it's hard to do a follow-up
experiment and learn more about it you
know if if it is just the cosmological
constant which I think it probably is
then we're not going to learn anything
more about it experimentally we're just
going to measure its value more and more
precisely it is literally just one
number
but it was completely unexpected for me
even though I'd written about it I'd
written papers about the possibility but
I would have bet against it and we still
haven't fitted into our view of the
world effectively so that's a big deal
before I was born of course carries a
lot more uh
history to it many many more years I I
don't know if it's a single Discovery
but I think quantum mechanics is the
most mind-blowing physics Discovery
because classical mechanics was so good
everyone it was very very natural to
think that was just the right answer and
we were just going to tweak it and find
the specific forces and particles and
things like that and the idea there was
a completely different paradigm was
mind-boggling and on the one hand it's
to our great credit as human beings that
we were able to
shift gears toward it that quickly and
on the other hand it's to our great lack
of credit that we haven't followed up
that we have not yet completely
understood quantum mechanics and often
ignore the attempts to understand it
flyback says you and other Quantum
physicists talk often of particles being
entangled with their environment while
often referencing domains that are
relative to our scale the scientist lab
Etc is an atom also considered an
electron's environment do electrons
within atoms necessarily become
entangled with each other generally
speaking I'm curious about the
philosophical concept of environment its
boundaries and the effects of scale upon
it
good I think it's good to be curious
about that
um it is a tricky philosophical Concept
in part because
it's one that makes perfect sense in a
certain regime right in a certain limit
like the environment you don't need to
be doing quantum mechanics to talk about
an environment throughout the history of
thermodynamics a very common thing to
contemplate is taking some physical
system and embedding it in a heat bath
right so the system itself might be at
whatever temperature but you're
embedding it in an environment at a
different constant temperature and the
idea of the heat bath is it's so big
that the system can absorb or exchange
energy with it but the heat bath doesn't
itself change its temperature or any
other features it just absorbs
everything that the system does to it
that's clearly an approximation right
and the same thing is true for a quantum
mechanical environment that we talk
about in decoherence it's a convenient
higher level emerging thing it is not a
sharp bright line that you can draw
electrons in atoms are generally
entangled with each other but that's not
an environment because we can keep track
of them the environment is literally
when we lose the ability to keep track
of everything that is going on okay we
can't keep track of all the atoms in the
air around me or all the photons hitting
the walls of the room or anything like
that so we group it up and call it the
environment so doing that better and
better is important I don't want to
downplay the importance of really
thinking through when we should think of
something as the environment and when we
should think of something as the system
ashmeet Singh and I wrote a whole paper
about exactly that Quantum myriology uh
so it's an important problem to to get a
handle on but it's not one you should
expect a once and for all final answer
to it's going to depend on the context
depending on your observational handles
on the situation and so forth
Francois varshon says in the solo
episode why is there something rather
than nothing you mentioned that the
answer could simply be a brute fact that
requires no further explanation do you
have any examples of other questions
that can be answered with a similar
brute fact explanation if possible one
question that is more down to earth less
intimidating than the question of
existence of everything
um yeah I think there's plenty of brute
facts out there the problem with brood
facts is that even though I think that
they probably are out there in other
words there are probably features of our
universe that could have been different
but don't have a deeper cause or
explanation for them that's what I mean
by a brute fact and in that sense I
think there probably are plenty of root
facts but the problem is we don't know
which ones they are right I mean and I I
do try to say in the case of why is
there something rather than nothing
that's that's an example of when we
don't know if it's a brute fact or not
that question is so deep and profound uh
so wide in scope that it is one of the
ones where I am most likely to say yeah
that's probably just a brute fact it's
hard to imagine something deeper that is
explaining it
um but I don't know maybe there is an
explanation out there so it's perfectly
legitimate to look for deeper
explanations but I think but my point is
always that just because you would like
there to be a deeper explanation does
not mean it's not actually just a brute
fact so we need to keep the pop
possibility that certain things are
brood facts on the table and evaluating
them against the other possibilities
that are out there
Siddhartha says oh yes remember at the
beginning of the in the intro I
mentioned that Siddhartha had uh
constructed a well let me read what's
dartha says this is the thing that I was
referring to in the intro since you
mentioned having already answered many
questions in all the amas you have done
I finished extracting the questions and
answers for all amas that have a
transcript into a table format for Handy
reference and searching and there's a
link I'll put the link on the website I
plan to keep this updated for new amas
maybe you want to have a version of this
on your website as well yes I think
that's a great idea I will try to do
that so thanks uh to Siddhartha from me
and from everyone who might want to use
that and because you've done that
wonderful service I will absolutely
certainly answer your question which is
the following the novella anxiety is the
dizziness of Freedom by Ted Chiang
describes a device that after performing
a Quantum measurement to create two
branches allows people to communicate
between the parallel humans in the two
branches and some of the consequences of
such a device in human society one of
the effects the books describe drives is
say just one oxygen molecule is in a
different place because of a measurement
one way or the other that can have
large-scale chaotic effects on the
weather and even the DNA of babies born
a year later after the measurement in
the two branches
is this really likely How likely is it
that you're jumping left or right on
stage depending on the quantum
measurement leads to a different weather
or due to Chaos Theory I would say the
answer here depends on how we construe
the phrase How likely is it so remember
in many worlds uh lots of unlikely
things happen there are worlds where
super duper unlikely things happen
compared to the other worlds but they're
there they exist right so there's worlds
where there are dramatic differences but
the likelihood that we would ever be one
of the people living in those worlds is
very very small in the future so I don't
really worry about those that's not I
think the important question here I
think what you're answering what you're
asking is How likely is it not just that
somewhere out there in the wave
functioning the universe it exists but
How likely is it that two versions of us
existing on different branches of the
wave function having only recently
branched apart from each other we'd find
ourselves in very different worlds
the answer to that question it's
certainly possible but it's not
inevitable because there is chaos that's
true but there's also sort of
dissipation and convergence so it is
absolutely possible to get completely
different uh locations of individual
atoms and molecules in a particular box
of gas or something like that just
because we moved one oxygen molecule a
little bit
but think about literally a box of gas
right so if I have a an exact
description of all the atoms and
molecules in a box of gas I'm laplace's
demon classical mechanics is true let's
imagine they're just bouncing off each
other like little billiard balls then I
can predict exactly the future if I move
one atom or introduce a different atom
or something like that those bounces
will subtly start to deviate and very
soon all of the atoms in the Box will be
in different positions than they would
have been okay then in the original
configuration
so in some sense that world is now very
different all the atoms are in different
positions but guess what with
overwhelming probability from the
macroscopic level that box still looks
like a box of gas with a uniform
temperature and density Etc so there's
actually not a big macroscopic
difference even though microscopically
things are very very different that's
why it is hard to answer this question
there will absolutely be microscopic
differences the question is not just do
they chaotically
spread through the system but do they
macroscopically amplify and I think
that's going to just depend on a lot of
physics that I don't specifically know
you can easily imagine that it's a big
effect I mean this is literally what
Schrodinger's cat was about right the
reason why Schrodinger had to invent
this Rube Goldberg apparatus was to take
a small Quantum superposition and
amplify it to a macroscopic difference
so does that happen automatically is the
question well it could happen you know
if a certain variation in the location
or firing of neuron in someone's brain
causes them to act differently to push a
button or not push a button right and
that amplifies their effects but whether
that happens automatically I don't know
how frequently it does I'm sure it does
I don't know how often it does
you and McKay says
I started my PhD in theoretical
biophysics this year and I'm attending
my first conference soon with a poster
so congratulations you and that's great
as someone who has presumably been to a
lot of physics conferences do you have
any advice on getting the most out of it
yeah I think it depends a lot on your
uh conference did conferences are very
different and what you're doing there
you know I think that as a young person
starting a new uh PhD I would mostly be
in learning mode at a at your first big
conference so you have your poster I
would not hinge too much of your
self-worth on how many people come to
visit your poster or read it or anything
like that because it's just
unpredictable there's just too many
things that are outside your control
when it comes to things like that do a
good job on the poster don't put too
many words or equations on it everyone
does but and everyone tells you not to
do it but everyone does it anyway I will
tell you not to do it uh and you'll do
it anyway that's just what happens in
these things but even if no one comes
maybe you get a huge line maybe no one
comes don't sweat that too much I would
say you know you're like you said you
just started a PhD there's a large
landscape of things out there to learn
and you know the thing about doing a PhD
is it generally involves very intense
very concentrated work in an environment
that has you know your advisor your
fellow students postdocs whatever but
it's a very particular small scale
environment and there's a whole rest of
the world out there
and you know it's a cliche to say if you
get a postdoc you should go somewhere
far away or if you go to graduate school
you should go somewhere different than
where you went to undergraduate but it's
really even more true than they say
because there are different attitudes
towards what makes good science how to
do it which questions are interesting
where the field is going and you can
easily get very parochial just by
hanging out in one single research group
or even one single University so a
conference is an opportunity not just to
learn more technical things and hear
some talks but to talk with people who
are not the ones you talk to every day
talk about theoretical biophysics ask
them what they're working on why they're
working on it what do they think are the
most interesting things talk to young
people talk to senior people like
everyone is there to talk about
biophysics right so this is your
opportunity to you know really get to
know the community in a very real way
and the good news is that at your second
or third conference you will recognize
people from the first conference and you
will begin to realize oh like here's my
cohort here are the other people the
same age as me here are the big names in
the field and what they're doing and
you'll begin to get a sense for
um this complicated hard to characterize
semi-autonomous thing that we call the
community of researchers in your field
so I think that's what I would aim to do
more than anything else there's lots of
things to do you also have some drinks
in the bar and relax a little bit or if
you don't drink then at least relax a
little bit one way or another don't
overwork and stress yourself too much
Keith says in theoretical Neuroscience
I've recently had to become more
familiar with renormalization groups and
course graining methods when
investigating potential power law and
critical behavior in neural systems I
know there are similar approaches in
other complex systems such as social
sciences and economics including by
former mindscape guest Simon Deo my
question is how do these statistical
renormalization groups apply to these
emergent levels relate or compared to
the renormalization and fundamental
physics made famous by Feynman and
schwinger in QED and apparently hard to
do with gravity yeah that's a great
question I wish that uh we made it more
clear when we talked about
renormalization hopefully I will try to
do that in the book that I'm currently
writing
um the history is that these ideas
started in Quantum field Theory because
people invented Quantum field Theory
people like Dirac and Fermi and so forth
and they wrote equations down Heisenberg
people like that and they found that it
was pretty easy to get an infinitely big
answer right
um Feynman of course showed us how to
convert the equations that already
existed into the diagrams that we now
famously know as Feynman diagrams but
one way or the other whether they were
diagrams or not
there were quantities that you were
trying to compute that gave Infinity
when they really shouldn't so Feynman
and schweger Dyson tomanaga and others
figured out a set of mathematical
techniques for basically taking a limit
right for turning an apparently infinite
quantity into a finite one it got a bit
of a bad reputation because it's kind of
like making sense of infinity minus
infinity but really it was perfectly
respectable all along
it was still a little bit unclear
why you had to do it but one thing that
was clear was that these theories fell
into two categories ones some of them
have the property we call renormalizable
and some are non-renormalizable in both
cases you can get finite answers the
difference is that in the renormalizable
theories you only have to fix a finite
number of parameters in order to do that
you get an infinite set of of terms that
you add up to get the final answer but
those that infinite set of terms only
depends on some discrete finite size set
of numbers
in the non-renormalizable theories every
one of the infinite number of terms
you're adding up requires new input
requires a new parameter to fix it so it
doesn't really it's impossible to make
any predictions because you don't know
what the numbers are in the terms
further down the series and gravity
falls into that ladder category it's not
renormalizable in that sense and so
people had a rough feeling that it
couldn't possibly be a fundamental
Theory a theory that was not
renormalizable is not predictive and
therefore it can't be the once and for
all Final Answer To Nature
um
that changed in in sort of a skew ways
when Ken Wilson came on the scene and
also other people Leo cadenov and
Michael Fisher from the condensed matter
side of things started thinking of
renormalization in terms of energy
scales and length scales and rather than
just saying I'm subtracting Infinity
minus infinity Wilson and Friends showed
that you should think about
renormalization as only keeping track of
what happens down to a certain length
scale or below a certain energy scale
and we don't know what happens it's
super duper short distances or super
duper High energies therefore take
whatever does happen and bundle it up
into some unknown quantities which you
then characterize and so it's those
unknown quantities you're characterizing
that are the renormalization constants
or actually normalization parameters
that can flow as you change that energy
scale you're looking at
so it was a better philosophical
perspective on renormalization rather
than just being a trick to make an
infinite number seem finite it was a
physical understanding of why certain
things are renormalizable certain things
were not certain terms are big certain
terms are small Etc it all has to do
with
our ignorance and knowledge at different
length scales Okay so
that latter Insight is what potentially
is useful in complex systems social
science economics also engineering and
chemistry in a whole bunch of other
places look at the world scale by scale
rather than Point by point in space
that's the fundamental Insight of renew
normalization Theory and it's doable is
the nice thing in Quantum field Theory
it's very doable and these other fields
maybe it works maybe it doesn't you
gotta tell me Keith this is your job or
Simon's job I suppose but maybe it does
and I think it's very possible but I
would I would take the actual original
work by Feynman and schweger Etc as more
a step along the path to this way of
thinking about things if what you're
really asking is do I have to read
Feynman and schwinger or read about five
minutes Winger to apply renormalization
group ideas to neural systems no you
don't because neural systems are that
themselves finite there's no Infinity
there because you're never tempted to go
down to infinitely small length scales
like you would in a Quantum field Theory
Lars Krueger says as far as I know we
can't get any information about the
internal structure of a black hole but
why can't we draw a conclusion about
conclusions about it by observing the
exact shape of its Event Horizon
shouldn't The Event Horizon have valleys
and mountains due to the uneven
distribution of matter inside
well you might think that but then
people did the math right this is I say
this over and over again but
the words are helpful the words are nice
the words give us Insight it's the math
that matters at the end of the day and
uh Roger Penrose former mindscape guest
and Stephen Hawking and Robert Garrosh
and others in the 60s and 70s proved
theorems that said that black holes do
not have valleys and mountains due to
the uneven distribution of matter inside
what happens to the valleys and
mountains you would expect to be there
they are basically smoothed out by the
black hole emitting gravitational
radiation so if you tried to make a
black hole in a shape that was anything
other than
either perfectly spherical or an oblate
Sphere for a spinning black hole it
would quickly settle down to that shape
by shaking off those inhomogeneities uh
through gravitational radiation and it
happens very very quickly so black holes
are essentially all the same that is the
no hair theorem it's not quite a theorem
but uh in given certain assumptions you
can show that that's going to be the
case
Dutch cheese says a sociology and an
economics professor in a discussion
remarked that they didn't understand why
people were smoking and why younger
people took
sometimes so much risk while older
people were so much more careful but
having much less life ahead of them it
was simple all simply not rational but I
just see it as behavior that could
potentially lead to more offspring when
I was younger I also smoked because the
pretty and cool people also seem to be
smoking do you have thoughts about
Evolution and rationality I do have
thoughts in fact as I am
giving this answer here in real time I'm
realizing that later this month we have
a podcast about exactly this question so
maybe I shouldn't give too much Insight
here uh you'll get it later rather but
what I wanted to say specifically in
response to this question was
rationality is a tricky thing you know
when when you say oh look at those young
people they're smoking
um it's not rational well what do you
mean by rational like rational is
rationality is a procedure okay it's not
a result nor is it a norm it's not like
rationality is necessarily better than
irrationality but rationality only helps
us achieve our goals it doesn't tell us
what our goals are so I think that's
what you're putting your finger on and I
completely agree that maybe the goal is
not to maximize your future lifespan
there are other goals out there right
maybe you just like it in fact I think
that almost nobody lives according to a
set of rules that does nothing but
maximize their future life spans right
you certainly would never climb in a car
if that were the case
so I think that rationality is tricky
because sometimes you don't know what
goals are being pursued that's not to
say that people always are rationals
people are irrational all the time and
that's that's very clearly true so in a
complicated case a real world case like
why is this teenager smoking
um I would really not trust any wild
guesses that I made on the basis of my
own thought processes I would want some
actual careful investigation into what
were the reasons that that person gave
are they being honest with themselves
are they being internally consistent is
there a rational set of goals that they
could appeal to I don't know what the
answer is
um but it's we're too quick sometimes to
Proclaim what is rational behavior and
what is not
Moshe fader says your discussion with
Kiara mingarelli in mindscape212 about
using pulsars for detecting black holes
got me thinking about the extreme frame
dragging that a massive object spinning
at 100 Hertz or more must be doing and
all the more so for any spinning black
holes so I went to read up on frame
dragging and that led to the lens
starring procession and references to
gravito Magnetic and gravito electric
potentials terms I hadn't encountered
before on the analogy of
electromagnetism it seemed to suggest
the possibility of some sort of
reciprocal generation of the forces so
are the words gravito magnetic and
gravito electric terminology that can be
taken literally so we can someday build
gravity generators or are they
metaphorical like the colors in quantum
chromodynamics
so they can be taken literally they're
literally it's still an analogy but it's
a very close analogy gravity like
electromagnetism has electric aspects
and magnetic aspects I wrote a textbook
on general relativity called space-time
and geometry where you can read about
decomposing the gravitational field into
its electrical part and its magnetic
part
however that does not mean that someday
we will build gravity generators and the
reason why is because the magnetic and
electric words refer to the fields in
this case the um gravitational field or
the electromagnetic field but our
ability to control the fields requires
sources sources for the fields and the
sources for the electromagnetic fields
you know positively or negatively
charged particles have the hugely
important feature that they can cancel
each other out you can get both negative
charges and positive charges so either
particle would give you an electric
field but if you put them on top of each
other you get zero field
that is an enormously powerful thing
because you can take the same two things
an electron and a proton put them very
close to each other and have zero net
field and then just move them apart and
suddenly you have a field right or vice
versa so you can absorb Fields very
easily you can create Fields very easily
all of that stuff not to mention that
electromagnetism is much stronger for us
than gravity but in gravity you don't
have negative charges you only have
positive masses not negative masses
there's no case in gravity where you can
take two objects which have a
gravitational field put them on top of
each other and get zero gravitational
field so there's no way in a direct
analogy to the generation of electrical
forces that you can do the same thing
with gravity
Lothian 53 says when black holes Collide
they give off a huge amount of energy in
the form of gravitational waves when
this happens does it affect the
information contained in the black holes
do the gravitational waves carry the
information from inside the black holes
well there's I can appeal to another uh
one of these theorems that was proven by
Stephen Hawking and friends the area
theorem of black holes it's true that
when black holes Collide they do give
off gravitational waves and yet if you
take the area of the two black holes
separately before they collided The
Horizon area proportional to their mass
and for non-spinning black holes is
proportional to their Mass it's more
complicated that they're spinning but
same basic idea and then you let the
black holes Collide and they give off
energy and gravitational waves but they
haven't shrunk overall there is also
energy you know in the gravitational
pull between the black holes and the
area of the black hole the single black
hole that you made is always greater
than or equal to the combined areas of
the two black holes you started with you
cannot decrease the total surface area
of black holes by combining them so if
you think that the information is
proportional to the event horizon area
it does not go down when you take two
black holes and squeeze them together
schleier says I've come to believe that
I am a 99 non-sentient zombie my only
evidence of Consciousness occurs when
I'm thinking about Consciousness which
is not often all I am is this brief
instance of introspection occurring in
this brain at this place and time I will
cease to exist in a moment when my
mind's attention my mind's attention
wanders and it's back to zombie status
do you think you are conscious when you
are not thinking about being conscious
is this even a meaningful question
yeah I think as I said just earlier that
Consciousness is a complicated thing and
there's different aspects to it you seem
to be choosing an especially demanding
notion of Consciousness that you
literally have to be conscious of your
Consciousness to be conscious at all I
think that's not necessarily true I
think that's at least let's put it this
way not what most people have in mind
when they think about Consciousness when
you smell something and it smells like
cinnamon and you go Ah that's cinnamon
to most people that is a conscious
experience you go oh yes that smelled
like cinnamon you don't need to be
thinking oh yes I am conscious of
smelling cinnamon right that's not a
necessary part of the whole thing so
that's a different level maybe you want
to call them two different things and
one is consciousness and one is not but
that's just a matter of the definition
most more importantly I think that one's
attention to conscious introspective
experiences comes and goes yes your
mind's attention wanders but in the
conventional way thinking about
Consciousness the fact that you are
conscious a conscious creature does not
actually come and go I mean you're not
conscious in the usual sense when you're
asleep but you're still a conscious
creature who's just not activating their
Consciousness at that point in time I
think that's the way most people would
talk about it
James Swift says what dish or meal that
you prepare and cook yourselves at home
do you feel gives you the best return on
investment investment meaning effort
time cost or whatever you think is the
most interesting definition of
investment and return
I think it's an easy question for me uh
I I make
pan pizza and cast iron skillet that is
to die for I gotta say it is so good but
you'll never taste it because I'm gonna
eat the whole pan uh it's a pretty big
it's 12 inch Skillet it's a lot of pizza
and it's so good that I'm gonna eat the
whole thing it's not very involved I'm
not an expert pizza maker in any sense
you can go to Whole Foods and buy pizza
dough and buy pizza sauce and mozzarella
cheese and then you know I fancy it up
with
pepperoni and onions and oregano and
things like that garlic
but uh not that much effort huge payoff
so that's answering your question might
not be the best thing I make but in
terms of effort and and payoff it's the
biggest ratio there
but I will say I am trying to cook more
I've never been I've always been someone
who can cook a little bit a follower of
recipes but it's never been a major part
of my activities I'm also very happy to
go out or just do TV dinners or make
some spaghetti or whatever I'm trying to
be better at actually cooking real food
um
we have a a big house now and we can
have people over and cook for them and
you know what a part of our lives where
we have the jobs we want Jennifer and I
and we can have people over and we don't
need to worry about moving somewhere
else you know we're here for the long
term I gotta learn to some dishes to
cook uh had some people over very
recently and I made this Greek lemon
meatball soup that was really quite good
a huge amount of work because they have
to like make the meatballs but um it was
worth it because it was yummy and you
just can't buy that pre-made so I'm
trying to be better at that trying to
cook more it's both fun and uh creative
and better for you than just heating
something up in the microwave
crather Luca says in a recent podcast
you brought up the argument from
Evolution against moral realism
objectivism is this something you
believe in to me this is just an
argument that we need to do philosophy
to create moral progress rather than
relying on our instincts just as we have
to do science to create better theories
of the physical world rather than
relying on our instincts
you know I think I don't think that the
argument from Evolution against moral
realism is a very strong argument it's
certainly not a knock down argument but
it's suggestive it's one of the ways in
which you can sort of raise questions
about moral realism so for those who
don't remember or know the argument the
ideas basically look
if there was no moral realism if there
were no objective moral truths what
would happen in the world and you know
yeah there would be
people would exist right and they would
come up with rules as we talked uh
recently with Michael tomasello and
others people very naturally being
social creatures would invent rules
would invent standards by themselves
that uh correspond to ideas of good and
bad in other words we would invent
morality whether or not it was out there
and we would invent it for reasons of
evolutionary pressure because you know
we're trying to get along we're trying
to survive trying to pass down our
genomes Etc and the argument such as it
is is basically if you thought there
were objective moral truths out there
there's no relationship between those
objective moral truths and the ones that
we invent through evolutionary pressures
right
there's a total different set of reasons
why we invent our you know ways of
living socially then some out there in
the sky moral truths so why should you
think that these objective moral truths
just so happened to line up with
conventional human morality
as you can see it is not a knock down
argument because maybe they do just
happen to line up
um but I do think it's it's sort of a
winking acknowledgment of some of the
unrealistic attitudes unrealistic
aspects I should say of moral realism
it's much easier for me to believe that
we invented moral morality for reasons
of social interaction and evolution and
things like that and then attributed
objective reality to it even though we
had just invented it than it is for me
to believe that there really are
absolute moral principles out there that
we have discovered through thinking
really hard and we just keep happening
to discover ones that line up with what
we wanted to be true anyway that doesn't
seem very realistic to me
James Mahoney asks a priority question
we've gotten this far without a priority
question remember the idea of a priority
question is that everyone who asks AMA
question gets one chance in their lives
uh we're assuming that no one is going
to be living for thousands of years here
but uh one chance in your life to ask a
question that I will absolutely try to
answer because I can't answer all the
questions so if you have one that you
really really want to answered just
labeled a priority question I will give
it my best shot there is no guarantee
that I will do a good job answering the
question or that you'll be satisfied
with the answers sorry about that but I
will I will give it a shot so James's
question is I sent you a copy of my book
the logic of social science Princeton
University press and your philosophy
Department address I think you will like
it did you receive it if so would you be
able to glance through the beginning
parts and let me know what you think
so yes I did receive it uh it is very
relevant to things that at some point in
my life I want to think about the logic
of social science but no I've not read
it yet I just don't have time to read it
I a lot of things I need to do right now
I'm probably
busier and have more obligations right
now this this Academic Year than I ever
have in my life to be perfectly honest
so there's many things that I've been
blowing off and not doing and reading
books that come in the mail has been one
of them hopefully I will get to some
things later but as as of yet not yet
Jeremy Dittman says your fascinating
discussion with Joanna Hoffman on
designing future cities and the strategy
of employing a storytelling narrative
space made me think about your previous
mindscape guest T Nguyen and our human
tendency to construct simple narratives
that are false and ultimately unhelpful
for understanding what's going on
historically the development of the
scientific method seems like an antidote
to this over-reliance on simple
narratives to explain the world around
us do you think that there will be an
effective scientific method for
attacking complex systems still waiting
to be developed what Credence do you
assign to the storytelling Narrative
Approach to problem solving when it
comes to complex human systems
so I do think that we will we are and
will continue to develop an effective
scientific method for attacking complex
systems I think that the very phrase
complex systems doesn't necessarily map
on to any particular part of the world
in an easy way there's different kinds
of complex systems and they may
ultimately require different kinds of
analysis there do seem to be happily
some commonalities in the complex
systems that we know and love and maybe
we can leverage those commonalities to
improve our effective scientific
understanding
but there's also just you know rules of
thumb that you know there's ideas that
come along that we do realize are
helpful in understanding complex systems
that fall short of being really
scientific principles
um one such is that you know there can
often be oh this this actually has a
name uh I forget the name of the
principle but you know there's aspects
of complex systems that are a certain
way and no one can remember why they're
a certain way uh but they're really
important it turns out if you if you
stop them if you get rid of them
everything uh falls apart there's a
there's a conservatism that uh complex
systems naturally Inspire because tiny
changes can lead to large effects right
so these are these are not scientific
principles they're rules of thumb and
that is why I do think that this
storytelling Narrative Approach
um to problem solving can be relevant to
exactly this kind of situation these
complex human systems
um there's you know
coming up with good ideas is something
that we've not yet been able to turn
into an algorithm human beings can come
up with good ideas but we're not ever
completely sure how we do it or even how
to duplicate it next time and I'm all in
favor of using all sorts of different
techniques to inspire us to come up with
good ideas and there's something about
storytelling or fiction writing or
imagining future scenarios that nudges
us to think in slightly different ways
you know not just us to take certain
things seriously that you might not have
thought of or to think of aspects that
you might have overlooked it is far from
perfect there's plenty of examples of
stories and narratives that leave
important things out right but because
complex systems are so complex they're
hard to boil down to hard and fast rules
thinking in these more imaginative ways
I think can be absolutely helpful in the
foreseeable future anyway
says if Consciousness is the ability to
think of an internal self and theory of
mind is more or less the same but for
other people which do you think
developed first our ability to attribute
thoughts desires and intentions to
others or to ourselves
I love this question I have no idea what
the answer is uh I think it's a great
question I'm kind of surprised I never
thought of it before or no one else has
mentioned it to me or maybe they have
and I've just you know not paid
attention to it that's very very
possible
um but yeah did we first
start conceptualizing other people as
agents if you want to put it that way as
uh Michael tomsello talks about or do we
consider ourselves as agents I forget
even if tomasello
uh gave an answer to that question even
though he wrote a whole book about the
evolution of agency so I'm sure he would
have an informed answer to this question
and I don't I think I would guess
that we did it to other people first in
some sense right I mean you have we
developed models of the world
and that we need to do that to get
through life even you know way before we
become human beings evolutionarily
speaking
um there are models of the world like if
you do this then that will happen
animals definitely have such models and
so of course you're going to include
others in your model of the world right
I mean my cats absolutely have an uh
thought that if they act in certain ways
I will respond in certain ways do they
have self-consciousness where they think
of their own intentions and desires
probably not so therefore on the basis
of that conjecture I think that we
probably developed
um
we probably started thinking about
others first in these ways but maybe
that's maybe I'm skipping over the
importance of not just having a model of
other people but the that model
including the idea of agency so I really
don't know I think it's a good question
Aaron Munger says is there an easy way
to think about the more
counter-intuitive cases of growing
entropy examples such as oil and water
becoming cleanly separated into layers
or a big cloud of atoms that will Clump
into the planets of a solar system I
have a hard time seeing how there are
more ways to arrange the parts of the
higher entropy State while keeping the
macro State the same
you know
there are ways but maybe they're not
easy so I talk about both of these
examples in from eternity to here if you
want to read about it in both cases once
you dig into the details uh the oil and
water separating or the gas clumping
into a planet or a star
the entropy is going up in a very
standard way it's moving toward a
configuration where there are more ways
that the system can be arranged
the what is what is secretly going on
though is that the total Arrangements
that are possibly accessible by the
system include aspects That You Don't
See
so you think that something
counterintropic is going on in the case
of oil and water what's going on is that
the oil molecules are let me get this
right either hydrophilic or hydrophobic
they they're hydrophobic they don't like
water so if they were let's let me try
to get it right it's been a while since
I wrote that book and I'm not a chemist
by any stretch if you have an oil
maybe they're hydrophilic you know maybe
they're hydrophilic if you have an oil
molecule in a water molecule they tend
to lock together right they tend to like
arrange into a certain configuration and
so it's only the combined system of the
two molecules that can move around and
have degrees of freedom whereas if
they're separated they can both move
around independently so the entropy is
actually higher the number of accessible
States is actually higher when they're
separated so they like to just
completely separate and have a boundary
between them in the case of the gas and
dust collapsing to a black hole sorry to
a star or a planet
that only happens because the system can
shoot out some escaping atoms or dust
grains or whatever so the momentum in
the escaping bits is very high and the
total amount of phase space available in
high momentum escaping things is Big so
when you take the momentum as well as
the position into account it's a higher
entropy State when the When Gravity is
important for things to be lumpy than
for things to be smooth so in both cases
they're moving towards
macroscopic configurations where there
are more possible configurations but you
don't see the relevant parts of the
configurations with your eyes so you're
getting tricked
red Antonov says is there a past guest
you would like to write a paper with
what would it be about
this is a good question that I'm not
going to give a very good answer to uh I
have written papers with a couple of
past guests um Adam Reese my current
Johns Hopkins uh colleague and discover
one of the discoverers of dark energy I
I can I could elaborate with him and
with the group on one of their early
papers
um the hi-z Supernova team and of course
uh Scott Aronson and I wrote a paper
together I think that's it among the I
I've come close with a couple of other
guests but yeah I'm thinking about this
I don't think I've collaborated I feel
very bad sorry guests that I have had on
the show that I'm not remembering the
papers we wrote together but um
probably there's a bunch of people who I
would like to write a paper with but I
yeah I mean um there's there's just a
finitude of energy and effort available
here
um I have to prioritize what I'm doing
you know there's a lot of ideas that pop
up uh during the podcast that I just
don't have time to chase down and uh you
know it takes work to write a paper
writing a paper is not just having an
idea that's the easy fun part then it's
like months of effort to really think
through that idea read other papers that
other people have written relevant to
that idea come up with some examples or
some calculations you can do
um you know to make it into a
substantial of enough investigation that
it's worthy of being a publishable paper
so you know who knows my my uh like I
said between moving to Hopkins and
writing books and things like that my
research has slowed down recently I'm
very very much looking forward to
getting back on my feet there and I have
a whole bunch of things I want to
get done maybe some of them will be in
collaboration with former guests
Steve Wood says priority question I'm
genuinely curious about how you see your
audience and what you honestly expect
them to understand I've been wrestling
with this question since way back in
episode 36 with David Albert I fully
accept that I may not be informed enough
in many of the physics categories you
discuss but how many of us do you think
are is the kind of conversation and the
kind of abstraction going on in that
Albert podcast meant to tease us baffle
us motivate us to reboot our entire
education or just impress us what do you
really expect to achieve with these
discussions beyond anything like social
status building I don't ask that to be
rude I just wonder who benefits
um yeah the the intention is absolutely
to help you understand things
um different people might achieve
different levels of understanding
listening to different podcasts
different guests might be better at
using words that everyone can understand
and others might not you know that's the
nature of of the game the nature of
doing a podcast where I'm talking to
other people is that I do not have
complete control over what those other
people say you know I try to do my best
to bring on guests who I think are very
interesting and have something important
to say that can be made understandable I
personally did not find the David Albert
podcast to be that difficult to
understand even compared to some other
podcasts but I get that depending on
what you're used to reading and thinking
about it might have seemed impenetrable
because of different parts of
um the vocabulary or whatever that
that's perfectly fine but
it is it certainly has nothing to do
with social status building right if
anyone is under the impression that
they're going to build up a lot of
social status by listening to mindscape
then keep listening but I would change
your motivation for doing so
Gregory kusnik says Nikki Haley thinks
we should have competency tests for
older politicians my feeling is that if
we're going to have such tests they
should apply to everyone not just the
old what do you think
yeah I don't think we should have
company competency tests for older
politicians or for anyone at all I don't
know I I mostly can't imagine what kind
of test would do good right like I get
the motivation you know you want your
politicians to be competent
um you know I I think that certain it's
beyond a doubt that some politicians get
to be a certain age begin to lose their
competency and yet stay in office for
various reasons right but I think that
the solution to that I think that's bad
but I think the solution to that is not
competency tests that just seems like a
cheap gimmick to me
um
we have to act like you have to be more
serious about it ask yourself the
question why is it possible for someone
who might not be that competent to
nevertheless win an election right and
that has to do with all sorts of things
largely involving the benefits of
incumbency
um whether it's fundraising or name
recognition or what have you uh I don't
I think that incumbents have too much of
an advantage overall and I think that
that's a bigger problem than people
getting old and
um less competent so that's what I would
aim at not uh cheap gimmicks like
competency tests
okay we've reached the end of the AMA
there's one more question to go this is
kind of a fun one from Nick Gall I'm
fascinated well I think it's fun I mean
you might not think it's fun Nick Gall
says I'm fascinated by the issue of how
Hilbert space is carved up into
classical macroscopic objects AKA
systems or entities and environments but
I'm confused by the lack of any unified
terminology there seemed to be so many
different names for this issue in
different contexts decompositional
equivalence defining wave function
branches physics from scratched
preferred basis preferred decomposition
Quantum factorization Quantum eriology
Quantum reality set selection static
State what's a system and then their
names attached to all these including my
own quantumeriology with ashmeet Singh
so the question is the lack of unified
terminology makes finding papers on the
issue very difficult what why is the
terminology so fragmented and when do
you think it'll become more Unified
so
I get that this can be frustrating this
is part of what you know is what makes
research hard is that there might be
something out there in somebody else's
paper that is really relevant to what
you're doing and yet you don't know
about it and you can't find it even
though you looked and the best is when
you end up writing your paper anyway and
then someone sends you a a annoyed irate
email saying why didn't you write my
paper clearly you hate me and you have
to say no I didn't know your paper
existed because it has nothing to do
with my personal feelings toward you or
disregard for your work so this is a
problem
um but there's a reason why it's a
problem there's two reasons actually or
there's a reason why the the situation
is what it is one is that even though
the various terms that you have cited
here all fall into the general bucket of
carving up Quantum States in their
evolution in useful ways many of them
have slightly different
uh actual physics questions that they
are pointing at
um you know the preferred basis problem
is a pro guess what a problem about a
basis in a vector space whereas a
preferred factorization or decomposition
is a question about subsystems not about
basis States and those are two different
things even though they're all in the
bucket of trying to carve the world up
in ways that are useful to us as big
macroscopic people so that's part of it
that these really aren't exactly the
same but the other part is this is an
area that has not received that much
attention I mean you're listing you know
a dozen papers but that's a drop in the
bucket compared to you know the total
number of Papers written about quantum
mechanics one way or the other uh this
there's not a coherent group of people
who are dedicated to the idea of
understanding how to carve up the wave
function into classical bits I wish
there were I am trying to you know build
up exactly an enthusiasm for this kind
of research but
in a situation where a set of questions
is not yet popular people are thinking
about it but it really hasn't taken over
uh really hasn't grabbed the imagination
of a large swath of people and we don't
know the answers to the questions and
we're kind of feeling out what the
answers are it's very natural that
people are going to invent their own
terminology for what they consider to be
slightly different things the hope is
that it all kind of settles out what is
the word I'm looking for here shakes out
that eventually we get together and talk
to each other back and forth and agree
on what the right words are you know
some of these phrases Quantum reality or
what's a system these are not very
helpful these are not very specific
um
labels for the things that we're
thinking about uh and you know preferred
basis or pointer bases is a good one but
it's a different question here so I
think we'll get there you know patience
you know as time goes on and you you
um cite this website by Jess Riedel who
has done a very good job at bringing
together some of these different things
and that's that's how the academic
project works is that people write
papers they try their best to cite each
other sometimes they fail other people
collate different papers and point them
out and try to bring them to other
people's attention I mean you might
remember or not remember but you might
uh know the story that when whoever it
wrote his story wrote his thesis about
many worlds no one paid any attention to
it uh that was in the 1950s and he left
Academia so the fact that he left
Academia meant there was no person out
there popularizing his idea okay and
turns out that's a super important
aspect of the research process it turns
out that Bryce DeWitt was the editor of
the journal in which he published his
paper so he knew about it and over a
decade later in 1970 DeWitt wrote a
paper in physics today
popularizing and he labeled it the many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics and then people started paying
attention to it you know as we talked
about many times on the podcast with say
Neptune and other people
attention is the coin of the realm
there's a million things going on in the
world what are you paying attention to
who are you listening to who like we
talked about this at the very very
beginning with the black hole paper
that's supposed to be dark energy I
certainly think that I could if I spent
a day or two read through this paper
really understand all the equations and
come to an informed judgment about
whether or not it's on the right track
but there's a million papers I can't do
that for all the papers right I can't
even read the abstracts of all the
papers that come out every morning
there's just too many of them so you
need some filters you need some filters
to decide what to pay attention to and
for this particular set of questions
about dividing up the wave function of
of a big system it was it's never been
pressing because people thought they
knew what the subdivisions were when
they have two electrons in front of me I
have two electrons and I combine them to
make a two electron system this inverse
problem of starting with a combined
system and asking how to divide it up
isn't one that has been very pressing so
people don't pay attention to it
I think as we push forward into
understanding the foundations of quantum
mechanics and quantum gravity people
will pay more attention to it and in the
process we'll pick some words and stick
with them we will pick some terminology
that makes sense but the exciting go go
early days are never going to be that
crisp and clean that is a motto to keep
in mind for the foundations of quantum
mechanics as well as for everything else
in life so with that thanks very much
for listening to the AMA talk to you
next week slash month keep going bye bye
oh
[Music]
mama